So, da bin ich. Ich dachte mir, ich mache euch mal ein bisschen wach.
Moin. Wer es nicht kennt, das ist der Black Ops 1 Zombie Soundtrack.
Mega geil. Leider irgendwie danach ein bisschen untergegangen.
Ja, genau. Das ist eines der besten, finde ich, zumindest so Gaming
Lieder, die extra nur für ein Game geschrieben wird. Ist voll untergegangen.
Ja.
Aber erst mal Black Ops 1 Zombie Soundtrack. Geht, glaube ich, in drei Minuten oder so.
Da sind wir wach.
Kommt eine runde Headbang.
Da war Max noch in der Ausbildung.
Ne.
Wann war Black Ops?
2011? Da war ich noch in meiner Ausbildung.
Vielleicht noch ganz knapp. 2010 noch ganz knapp vielleicht. Ja, ja.
Ich würde ja so gerne mal ordentliche Musik ab und zu hier im Stream spielen.
Weil nicht, dass die Nintendo Soundtracks und andere Sachen nicht irgendwie auch ein bisschen entspannend wären. Aber ab und zu mal so richtig ordentliches
Gegrunzel ist doch mal... Das geht ja auf Twitch nicht. Außer es ist Gaming Soundtrack.
Übrigens auch ein mega Soundtrack für alle, die so Musik mögen.
Ja, auch Poggers Soundtrack für alle, die sowas mögen.
Aber ich lasse euch gleich in Ruhe.
Ich weiß, dass es nicht für jeden was ist, aber ich mag sowas.
Ich meine, ich höre schon seit jeher. Also wirklich schon lange Musik in diesem Stile.
Weiß nicht. Was mit mir los war? Eigentlich bin ich zu jung.
Nicht zu jung.
Doch, zu jung. Ich meine, ich bin 1984 geboren.
So in meiner Schulzeit war eigentlich so richtig krasser Gangster Hip-Hop und sowas schon angesagt.
Wobei, es stimmt nicht.
So, ich hab's geschafft.
Ne, das stimmt gar nicht. Es war in meiner Schulzeit tatsächlich gar nicht so viel Gangster Rap angesagt.
Was in meiner Schulzeit angesagt war, war noch das...
War das noch davor.
Jetzt wollen wir gleich ein bisschen Kontrast.
Bisschen Happy Kirby Musik.
Ja, also in meiner Schulzeit... Es stimmt gar nicht.
Ich hab das damals so als krasse, richtig krasse Gangster Musik empfunden.
War's gar nicht. Das waren noch die Vorgänger zum größten Teil.
So Fantastische Vier und sowas waren das.
Das war noch der Vorgänger von dem heutigen ganzen Gangster Rap-Kram.
Da war Hip-Hop noch eher zum größten Teil lustig.
Ich muss sagen, ich bin da nie reingekommen,
wenn's auch die ein oder anderen Sachen gibt, die man sich anhören kann.
Also ich mein, ein bisschen später war Eminem übelst angesagt.
Da kann man sich die ein oder anderen Sachen geben.
Aber bei mir persönlich ist zu 95% Heavy Metal.
Oder, wenn ich irgendwie was mich konzentrieren muss für Progress-Stells oder sowas,
dann mach ich entweder Gaming-Soundtracks
oder irgendwelche Chill-Background-Elektro-Dinger
auf YouTube an und lass den Hintergrund dudeln.
Ich mach nicht 10 Stunden Kirby.
Das halte ich nämlich nicht aus.
Und ab und zu...
Beste.
Und ich würde ja gerne mal ab und zu auf Twitch,
so, keine Ahnung, ein Mal pro Stream oder so,
würde ich so ab und zu gerne mal ein oder andere meiner Lieblingssongs spielen.
Aber das geht ja leider auf Twitch nicht.
Sobald du das auf Twitch anmachst, wirst du...
Weiß nicht.
Ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung, was dann eigentlich passiert.
Wahrscheinlich kriegst du irgendeine Copyright-Claim nach einer Zeit.
Ich weiß, manche Streamer haben ja...
benutzen ja so eine Funktion,
dass im Wort was anderes drin ist als im eigentlichen Stream.
Wobei das streng genommen dich ja auch nicht schützt.
Das schützt nur, dass im Nachhinein jemand Twitch durchscannt
und dann sagt, ah, hier, aber der Max, der hat gestreamt.
Übrigens eine Sache, die mich extrem überrascht hat,
wo wir gerade in den ersten 5 Minuten, muss ich einfach mal,
dann legen wir los, was mich sehr überrascht hat,
und zwar das neue Gloryhammer-Album.
Wobei, so neu ist das gar nicht.
Das kam, glaube ich, schon vor 2 Monaten oder so raus.
Das hier.
Ich glaube, das habe ich sogar mal auf Twitter gepostet,
als es rausgekommen ist.
Aber ich habe das jetzt mal wirklich in Ruhe mir zur Gemüte geführt.
Das ist richtig gut geworden.
Ich habe ja gedacht, die sind durch, nachdem ihr Sänger abgehauen ist,
beziehungsweise sie einen Sänger rausgeschmissen haben.
Das letzte Mal.
Also, das nach dem letzten Album.
Aber richtig nice.
Also, wer auf Extrems, Leute, Extrem-Cheesy-Power-Metal steht,
dem wird das gefallen.
Ich meine, allein schon, wenn man sich Titel...
Ich meine, seriously.
Wer denkt sich bitteschön Titel aus mit...
Lass mal auf.
Wer denkt sich Titel aus wie
Holy Flaming Hammer of Unholy Cosmic Frost.
Da ist es vorbei.
Also, das ist genauso übertrieben,
genauso übertrieben, wie ich das anderen Österreichs auch.
Aber das ist wirklich mega nice.
Hat mich echt überrascht.
Und ansonsten...
Leg gerade...
Was ist denn so das?
Weiß es jetzt gerade aus dem Kopf.
Muss mal kurz bei Amazon gucken.
Nicht bei Amazon, bei YouTube Music.
Was ist es denn, was bei mir zum größten Teil in letzter Zeit läuft?
Ich habe in letzter Zeit gar nicht so wirklich...
Wirklich viel Zeug.
Wirklich viel Zeug gehört.
Also, bei mir...
Okay, zeigt mal hier, YouTube Music.
Powerwolf.
Powerwolf auch immer mega nice.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich finde den neuen Sänger auch fein.
Also, ich habe ja erst gedacht,
so ein bisschen, naja,
so, weiß nicht.
Habe ich noch nie benutzt.
Aber finde ich vollkommen in Ordnung.
Also, passt.
Man könnte fast sagen, passt.
Also, es ist ja nicht viel Unterschied.
Passt fast ein bisschen besser als der alte.
Der alte hat sich, glaube ich, auch ein bisschen schwer getan.
Ich habe ein paar Live-Auftritte gesehen.
Das war nicht so vorteilhaft.
Also, ich war nicht live da.
Ich habe mir Live-Auftritte auf YouTube angeguckt.
Das ist ja immer so ein Ding,
mit wie gut da auch die Soundqualität ist und sowas.
Aber das sah schon ein bisschen anstrengend aus, ja.
Also, was habe ich denn hier?
Was ist bei mir denn auf YouTube Music angesagt in letzter Zeit?
Okay, Powerwolf
ist angesagt.
Blind Guardian ist angesagt.
Wikinger, Wikinger Heavy Metal ist angesagt.
So, mehr zeigt es jetzt gerade nicht an.
Listen Again, Listen Again.
Ja, also, YouTube Music ist nicht wirklich hilfreich.
Das zeigt mir an, okay,
du hast Blind Guardian gehört, ein Album.
Und dann zeigt es mir fünf Songs aus dem Album an
unter Listen Again.
Wo ich mir denke, Moment,
wenn du mir das Album anzeigst, YouTube Music,
dann musst du mir nicht die Songs aus dem Album anzeigen.
Also, YouTube Music ist wirklich extremly pepega.
Aber ich benutze YouTube Music,
weil es bei YouTube Premium, oder wie das heißt, dabei ist.
Ja.
So, ich muss ja meine VrM starten.
Wir müssen mal Updates machen, wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Leute, mir tut der Bob es gar nicht mehr so sehr weh.
Ich habe jetzt ja, wie gesagt, ich habe euch ja erzählt,
ich habe ein neues Fahrrad.
Und die ersten paar Sachen haben mir echt der Hintern wehgetan,
nachdem ich gefahren bin.
Aber ich bin gestern, ich bin gestern nochmal 30 Kilometer gefahren.
Jetzt ist es heute schon gar nicht mehr ganz so schlimm.
Also, ich glaube, ich gewöhne mich so langsam an den Sattel.
Zumindest weiß ich jetzt wieder exakt,
wo meine Sitzknochen sind.
Äh.
Ach doch, wenn man weiter scrollt, sieht man,
wenn man weiter scrollt bei Listen Again,
sieht man tatsächlich noch was auf YouTube,
auf YouTube Music.
Und zwar sieht man dort Demons and Wizards.
Ja, das ist, also es ist dieses Crossover
aus Blind Guardian und Iced Earth.
Wobei, gibt es, gibt es Iced Earth überhaupt noch?
Da ist doch, da war doch der Sänger,
ne, nicht der Sänger, der, der, der,
der, der, der Gitarrist, glaube ich, war das.
Der war doch verwickelt irgendwie in diese Trump-Kapitol-Geschichte
da in den USA, was vor ein paar Jahren war.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es die überhaupt noch gibt.
Können wir mal was mit Kotlin machen?
Ne neue Android-App oder so?
Ich, haben wir nicht sogar Kotlin mal ausprobiert?
Vor nur nicht allzu langer Zeit?
Ich meine, wir haben keine Android-App gemacht,
also da war ich überhaupt nicht in der Lage,
solche advanceden Sachen in Kotlin zu machen, ne?
Also, komm, wir machen mal ein bisschen,
ey, wir machen jetzt keinen Headbanger.
Komm, wir machen mal ein bisschen Wub Wub.
Wow!
Wub Wub Wub.
Wub Wub Wub ist immer so,
so geequalized, immer auf einen Sound,
ein Level.
Ja, wir haben Kotlin vor einem Monat gemacht,
stimmt ja, guck mal, Wub Wub TV.
Hammer doch hier.
Leute, ich muss übrigens ein bisschen aufpassen.
Ich habe mein Handy für die Arbeit vor mich gelegt,
weil es kann sein, dass mich heute,
wenn irgendwas kaputt geht, einer anruft.
Ich habe gesagt, ja, kein Ding, ich mache das heute.
Ich hoffe natürlich nicht, dass was kaputt geht,
aber man weiß ja nie.
Hier haben wir Kotlin gemacht, guckt mal.
Ja.
Collectionings, ja.
Aber meine, also ganz ehrlich,
ich habe nicht genug Kotlin-Skills,
um allen Ernstes irgendeine Java,
nicht eine Java, eine Android-App oder sowas da mitzubauen.
Das kannst du komplett knicken.
Meinungst du sowas wie React Native?
Ich finde, das ist eine richtig gute Sache.
Oder würdest du bevorzugt die Apps für jedes System Native
mit der gewünschten Sprache?
Nein, nein, würde ich nicht machen.
Das würde ich vielleicht machen,
wenn ich irgendwie so eine super,
Service hätte, der von bestimmten Sachen
auf den Geräten besonders profitiert
oder wenn ich irgendwie so eine Multimedia-App wäre
oder sowas.
Also wenn ich zum Beispiel,
ich habe jetzt vergessen, wie der Channel heißt,
den wir manchmal gucken,
der bei VibroTV ist.
Und die scheinen ja auch eine extra App
für iOS-Geräte und eine extra App für Android-Geräte zu haben.
Da verstehe ich das.
Das ist ja wahrscheinlich auch wirklich gut,
sowohl designtechnisch als auch feature-technisch
in die jeweiligen Plattformen integriert.
Aber für so eine normale App,
für irgendeinen Service,
ganz ehrlich, finde ich das deutlich besser handelbar,
wenn man das mit irgendeinem Framework baut,
was Cross-Plattform ist.
Solange es nicht, solange es nicht Maui ist.
Weil Maui ist für den Arsch.
Aber ansonsten finde ich React Native geil.
Also ich habe damit noch nicht viel gemacht.
Ja, ganz ehrlich.
Also ich würde keine App damit machen.
Aber wenn, wenn würde ich das damit machen?
Ganz ehrlich, ich würde es wahrscheinlich
gar nicht damit machen,
wenn ich nur ein bisschen,
ein bisschen was App-mäßiges brauche,
was sich vom Startbildschirm starten lässt.
Dann würde ich wahrscheinlich direkt eine PWA machen.
PWA-Support unter iOS wird ja auch immer besser.
Ich habe gehört,
die letzten iOS-Versionen hat schon mal einiges getan.
Es könnte sogar sein,
wir gucken mal, can I use?
dass Web-Notifications,
heißt das überhaupt so?
Ne, wie heißt denn das?
Notifications, einfach nur Notifications.
Dass das sogar Safari mittlerweile kann.
Im View Native gibt es auch, ja.
Es könnte sogar sein,
dass das mittlerweile,
guck mal, Colloidal, hier.
Ah, Partial Support, Partial Support.
Requires website to be first to edit to home screen.
Ja, vollkommen okay.
Guck mal, sogar,
da könnte ich jetzt den,
den Preis-Champion wieder rausbringen.
Der konnte nämlich noch keine Notifications auf iOS.
Guck mal, sogar, sogar Safari kann das.
Also man kann,
man kann wirklich viele Anwendungsfälle schon jetzt,
wenn ich das so sehe,
auch als PWA abbilden.
Dann musst du dir diesen ganzen Apple-Zertifizierungs-App-Store-Shit
nicht geben.
Natürlich hast du keinen Zugriff auf Native,
also außer über Browser-APIs,
wo das angeboten wird,
auf Native-Funktionen von dem Gerät
und kannst auch nicht auf irgendwelche iOS-APIs
direkt zugreifen.
Aber wenn man das braucht,
dann kann man ja an React Native oder sowas denken.
Also ich, ich würde es ehrlich gesagt bevorzugen
gegenüber App für jede Plattform.
Es sei denn,
man hat wirklich richtig handfeste Vorteile
auf der jeweiligen App.
Weil ansonsten musst du dir überlegen,
du drehst dich ja komplett am Rad.
Dann, dann brauchst du,
du brauchst eine App für Android,
brauchst eine App für Android TV auf jeden Fall,
weil die wird so,
auch wenn es Android ist,
die muss eh komplett anders aufgebaut werden.
Du brauchst eine App,
eine App für iOS,
eine App für Mac,
eine App für Windows,
ein App für iPhone,
noch für Fire TV,
da drehst du dich doch irgendwann am,
am Rad, wenn du da alles Native machen willst.
Also aus meiner,
aus meiner Sicht ist sowas wie React Native wirklich Pog.
Gerade wenn man ein,
ein Web-Service hat
und viele Web-Entwickler am Start hat,
dann ist das, glaube ich,
mit das Beste, was man machen kann.
Gibt ja noch mehr,
gibt ja noch Ionic und was es nicht alles heißt.
Ich wollte übrigens Package-Updates machen,
wo ich gerade dabei bin.
und alles. Es gibt ja mittlerweile tausend Varianten, um irgendwie Apps zu erstellen.
Ich hab gelesen, es gibt sogar mittlerweile für Leute, die sowas wie React Native verwenden,
sogar Web-Services, die deine Apps mit einem Cloud-Service bauen können, sodass du selbst
kein Mac mit Chat-GW hast, das ist Xcode, gell? Mit Xcode mehr brauchst. Aber was du
nach wie vor brauchst, ist ein Account und einen genehmigten Developer-Account für
Apple. Bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob du ein eigenes Code-Signing-Zertifikat brauchst.
Das ist natürlich immer ein bisschen kompliziert bei Apple. Aber ich hoffe, das Sideloaden
von Apps wird demnächst einfacher. Also, so sieht's aus. Und ich muss generell was
dazu sagen, unabhängig nochmal von Apps und sonst was betrachten wir mal jetzt nur. Flutter
ist übrigens auch nice. Ich hab keine Ahnung großartig von Flutter. Das, was wir bisher in
Flutter gemacht haben, hielt es sich in Grenzen, sah aber auch nach einer durchaus gangbaren
Lösung aus. Das Blöde an Flutter ist, dass Flutter auf dem Desktop noch so seine Probleme hat.
Zumindest das letzte Mal, als wir uns das angeguckt haben. Und ich glaube, das ist immer
noch so. Ich such da ab und zu immer mal ein bisschen so, was der aktuelle Stand ist. Ich
glaube, da gibt's immer noch die einen oder anderen Probleme. Was ich ja sehr gut finde an
Flutter, beziehungsweise was ich an allen UI-Frameworks mag, die das genauso machen wie
Flutter ist, wenn die UI-Frameworks ihre Controls selber malen. Das ist übrigens auch der Grund,
warum ich MAUI und vorher Xamarin.Forms überhaupt nicht mochte. Ich bin der Meinung,
ein gutes UI-Framework, gerade wenn du dich darauf verlassen können willst, dass deine App vielleicht
jetzt nicht Betriebssystem native aussieht. Aber seriously, Leute, ernsthaft. Guckt euch mal
Windows an. Nicht mal Microsoft selbst schafft es, dass Windows einen native look in irgendeiner
Art und Weise hat. Von welchem native look reden wir denn hier? Von diesem neuen native look? Von
diesem native look, wie der Calculator? Reden wir von diesem native look? Oder reden wir vielleicht
von diesem native look? Oder reden wir von diesem native look? Oder reden wir hier vielleicht von
noch besser? Noch besser reden wir von... reden wir von diesem native look? Guck mal, Microsoft
selbst kriegt das noch nicht mal hin. Microsoft selbst ist schon mal komplett unfähig. Das heißt,
es erwartet unter Windows niemand mehr heute eine App, die aussieht wie für Windows. Weil es gibt
keine Definition mehr, wie eine Anwendung für Windows aussieht. Das hat Microsoft einfach die
letzten 15 Jahre komplett verschissen. Deswegen ist eine App, die so aussieht wie gedacht,
finde ich viel wichtiger, wie eine App, die native controls verwendet. Man könnte vielleicht noch
sagen, ja unter Mac, wo das halbwegs einheitlich ist. Aber ganz im Ernst, dadurch, dass du dir so
viele Sachen sparst, dass du nicht mehrere Apps für jede Plattform entwickeln musst, finde ich,
Frameworks, die selber Controls zeichnen, ist das Einzige, was man verwenden sollte für
Cross-Plattform-Apps. Wenn man, wenn man Frameworks verwendet mit native controls,
dann kann man auch gleich eine native App machen. Ja, so viel, so viel. Deswegen mag ich auch
Avalonia deutlich lieber als Maui oder Samorin Forms. Deswegen finde ich den Ansatz von Flutter
hier auch ziemlich gut. Deswegen mag ich auch den Ansatz von Qt, also Q-T. Ich bin mir gar nicht
sicher, ob man das Qt spricht. Ich bilde mir aber ein. Ich habe das mal gehört. Ja, guck hier,
wie sogar Wikipedia sagt das. Guck mal, wie englisch Qt. Riecht man das? Die verfolgen den
ähnlichen Ansatz, den wir an der Wendy Controls selbst gemalt. Das ist, das ist, finde ich,
der richtige Ansatz. Alles andere ist Schrott. Deswegen mag jetzt der eine vielleicht anders
sehen als ich. Deswegen ist Elektron auch nicht verkehrt. Elektron hat einen enormen Vorteil.
Neben dem, dass es quasi ein Browser ist und dementsprechend auch seine Controls quasi selber
malt. Aber eines der größten Vorteile von Elektron sehe ich nicht nur im puren Cross-Plattform-Erstellen
von Anwendungen, die überall gleich aussehen oder zumindest überall mehr oder weniger so
aussehen. Hundertprozentig gleich muss es ja nicht mal sein. Mehr oder weniger so aussehen,
wie man sich das vorstellt. Ich glaube, der riesige Vorteil von sowas wie Elektron liegt,
ja, JavaScript ist auch ein gutes, gutes Stichwort Chat. Ja, liegt sicherlich auch
in JavaScript. Sag mal so, JavaScript im Browser und Node-Ökosystem, was ja im Prinzip Elektron
unter der Haube ist. Das ist ja eine Node gepaart mit einem Chrome plus Frontend halt
JavaScript, CSS, HTML. Und das, was auf OS-Seite Interaktionen machen muss, ist irgendwie auf
Node-Basis. Gibt ja ein paar Abkömmlinge von. Aber das ist eines der riesen Vorteile
neben Cross-Plattform ist, dass du alles benutzen kannst auf allen Plattformen,
was dir der Browser zur Verfügung stellt. Ich sage euch jetzt mal, wie es ist. Discord in der
Variante, wie es das heute gibt, die wären noch, die wären heute noch bei Beta 0 1,
könnten die nicht für Audio-Video-Funktionen zurückgreifen auf das, was Chrome schon alles
bietet für die unterschiedlichen Betriebssysteme. Überlegt euch mal, die würden sowas wie Discord
anbieten wollen mit Native App. Ja, ich weiß, dass das Discord Native Node Module benutzt und
sowas. Aber im Großen und Ganzen muss man sagen, überlegt euch mal, die wollten ernsthaft die
Funktionen von Discord. Discord ist extrem Multimedia heavy, Audio und Video. Ja, von
Screen Recording, Screen Sharing, Game Streaming, Animation, Sprache, Low Latency nach Möglichkeit.
Max, danke schön für den Sub. Jetzt überlegt euch mal, die würden das alles als Native App auf
den Support-Plattformen implementieren wollen. Die müssten die kompletten Discord-Audio-Video-Funktionen
implementieren auf iOS, Android, Windows, Mac und jetzt haltet euch fest, Linux. Und allein schon unter
Linux kriegst du ja Zustände. Was willst du machen? Willst du gucken, dass es ohne X gescheit aussieht?
Hoffst du mal, dass Wayland irgendwann mal da ihre fünf Sachen zusammenkriegt? Unterstützt du
Pipewire? Willst du lieber Low-Level-Alsa machen? Oder vielleicht doch lieber, wie hieß das andere,
Puls-Audio? Also allein schon unter Linux das zu supporten, ist abartig, ja. Und deswegen ist es
einfach richtig nice, dass es sowas wie Elektron gibt. Auch wenn ich mich über Elektron immer
lustig mache, ja. Richtig nice für genauso Sachen wie Discord ist Elektron einfach die perfekte
Grundlage. So, jetzt habe ich deine Frage sehr ausführlich beantwortet, denke ich. Max, was würdest
du empfehlen, um im Bereich Cyber-Security weiter aufzusteigen? Sein Marktwirt? Keine Ahnung, ich bin
nicht im Bereich Cyber-Security unterwegs. Ich würde mal sagen, sich auskennen ist auf jeden Fall
immer sinnvoll, egal in welchem Bereich. Zertifikate finde ich meistens nicht sonderlich sinnvoll, aber
sich auskennen und eventuell im Security-Bereich, da ist glaube ich auch ein bisschen, wie soll man
sagen, ein bisschen Exposure, nicht verkehrt, ja. Also wenn du vielleicht schon ein paar Talks gegeben
hast, wenn du schon ein paar Sicherheitslücken gefunden hast, wenn du schon ein paar SVE,
übrigens jetzt CSE, Moment, SVE, nee, CVE heißt es, gell? Alter, ich bin grad komplett verwirrt. Ja, genau, CVE,
falls du da irgendwelche Sachen gefunden hast, weiß ich nicht, ob es besser ist, ich habe es noch nicht ausprobiert.
Das macht sich sicherlich gut. Go haben wir auch schon mal im Stream gemacht, ist aber schon ein bisschen
länger her. Wir haben sogar im Stream schon mal Kobol gemacht. Android ist auch sehr einfach. Das Schöne an
Android ist, dass man einfach Apps sideloaden kann. Nicht so wie bei Apple, wo man um fünf Umwege dann
Apps sideloaden kann und dann werden die Apps auch wieder gelöscht und sowas. Das ist, ihr kennt meine
Streams, das ist Thema des Streams. Ja, siehste, sehe ich genauso. Übrigens, bevor wir anfangen, mir ist was
aufgefallen, Leute. Hat einer im Discord gepostet. Wir haben ein Problem, wobei, naja, ihr habt kein Problem,
ich eigentlich auch nicht, aber vielleicht muss ich ein schlechtes Gewissen haben und zwar, guck mal,
ihr erinnert euch doch daran, dass wir ein paar Videos geguckt haben von TheNativeWeb. Ja, wir haben zum
Beispiel Softwareentwicklung viel zu teuer geguckt, IT-Zertifikat und so. Da haben wir ein paar Videos von
geguckt und ich habe jetzt von dem Präsentator auf diesem Channel, auf seinem privaten Channel, Folgendes
und ihr könnt euch ja noch daran erinnern, ich habe einen Witz gemacht im Video, im Stream, dass der
Präsentator hier in den Videos, dass das bestimmt ein Echsenmensch ist. Er hat geantwortet, ach, habe ich gar
nicht gesehen, das habe ich noch nicht gesehen, dass es bestimmt ein Echsenmensch ist, weil er immer so
blinzelt und heute gucke ich bei ihm privat auf den Channel und was gibt es als nächstes Video?
Kono ist ein Echsenmensch und dann bin ich hier unten in die Beschreibung gegangen und hab festgestellt,
fuck, guck mal, das sind ja Videos von mir verlinkt. Ich hoffe, der hat es nicht ernst genommen. Ich hoffe,
der ist mir nicht böse, ey, da hätte ich echt ein schlechtes Gewissen, weil je nachdem, was ist, ich meine,
ich denke aus dem, aus dem, es ging aus dem Stream wirklich klar hervor, dass es halt ein Joke gewesen ist,
so Illuminati um die Ecke, aber je nachdem, wenn das was ist, jetzt stellt euch mal vor, ihr wurdet
vielleicht mit sowas früher schon mal übelst geärgert, da kommt so ein random Dude im Internet und macht sich
darüber lustig, vielleicht, vielleicht ist man dann echt sauer, so. Okay, was hat er denn geantwortet?
Bin ich gespannt. Oh, also ich habe noch geschrieben, ich weiß ja nicht, in welche Richtung das Video geht,
aber an der Timestamp habe ich ein schlechtes Gefühl, weil guckt euch mal die Timestamps an.
Schmerzhafte Erinnerung ist ein böswillig oder unbedacht, Verantwortung als Creator, alles hat
seine Grenzen und die Anonymität im Internet. Oh, fuck, ich glaube, der ist echt sauer, auch wenn das nie meine Absicht
gewesen ist. Okay, ich habe halt, ich habe halt geschrieben, ich habe jetzt echt schlechtes Gefühl, ich schaue deine Videos
mega gerne, ich wollte dich irgendwie nicht beleidigen oder so. Was hat er denn geschrieben? Ja, why not?
Klar, hätte ich sogar Bock drauf, könnte man durchaus, könnte man durchaus, ich glaube, da könnte man
durchaus was machen, austrimtechnisch, müssen wir mal gucken. Ja, vielleicht, vielleicht einfach nur,
weil er jetzt exposed wurde. Keck Alu, einfach ablenken. So, wo sind wir denn, wo sind wir denn
stehen geblieben? Ich wollte doch hier noch irgendwas zu sagen, genau. Was war eigentlich mit Avalon? Ja, fand ich gut,
fand ich gut. Wir hatten uns für React Native natürlich einen Sparer Entwickler, Zeit. Ja, ja, genau, genau so sehe ich das auch, ja.
Was ist Mojo oder Mojo? Wahrscheinlich Mojo, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das richtig ausspricht. Ich vermute mal Mojo, schon wieder
von Hipster Sprache. Das ist, das gucken wir uns jetzt gleich zusammen an, das ist ein Python Superset, aber ist Mojo
jetzt Open Source? Ne, leider nicht. Warum ich es teste? Weil ich Stream-Content brauche. Und sich letzten schon
wieder die Leute beschwert haben, Max, wir haben schon lange keinen Podcast-Stream mehr gemacht, das geht alles
den Bach runter, MonkaS. So. Kam Python 3.12 nicht gestern raus, habe ich überhaupt nicht verfolgt. Mojo ist nicht, ist noch
nicht Open Source. Ja gut, solange es nicht Open Source ist, ist es nicht Open Source. Ob die sagen, dass sie es machen
wollen, schön und gut. Ich verstehe übrigens nicht, warum es, ich kenne den FAQ-Eintrag, ich verstehe aber nicht, warum
es nicht Open Source ist. Heutzutage ist bei den meisten Sprachen sowohl die, also es gibt meistens einen halbwegs
offenen Sprachstandard, das ist auch bei C++, wobei, da fangen wir jetzt nicht an von der ganzen Thematik, ja. Aber es gibt
zumindest bei den meisten Sprachen gibt es eine Open Source Implementierung, also Referenzimplementierung. Meistens ist
sogar die Standard-Library und die Standard-Runtime und alles Open Source. Und das finde ich auch wichtig, man will
doch wissen, was am Ende in seinen Binaries drin landet. Zwift war Closed Source, ja gut, das ist von Apple, das
wundert mich nicht. Aber ich finde, ich finde wichtig, dass Sprachen, die man tatsächlich dann auch für produktive
Sachen verwendet, ich persönlich lege da sehr viel Wert drauf, dass das Ökosystem im Kern Open Source ist. Und wenn das
sogar Microsoft schafft, mit .NET und C-Sharp, also, ne, sollten das, sollten das andere auch hinkriegen. Ich glaube, es
gibt heute, Chat, fällt euch eine nennenswerte Plattform ein, die nicht Open Source ist? Ja, war außen vor, da gibt's
OpenJDK. Also, mir fällt, mir fällt so spontan, ok, SAP und Oracle-Zeug, ja, das würde ich, ja, weiß nicht, Vue Native
gibt's nicht mehr, ok. Also, mir fällt eigentlich nix ein. Lass, lass nochmal liegen. Also, egal was, Python, Open
Source, komplett. Implementierung, Runtime, Sprachstandard, Standard Live, alles Open Source. So, warte mal,
Most Used Programming Languages, Go, können wir schon mal weitermachen. Ja, das ist ja klar, da gab's doch bei
Stack, ja, ähm, gab's da nicht bei Stack, die Stack Overflow Umfrage? Ja. Moin, Patrick. So, da gab's doch hier,
die, gab's doch hier diese Umfrage. Ok, JavaScript, ja, alle Browser, ok, Safari, Safari nicht, aber alle, alle
gescheiten Browser. Also, JavaScript Engine, Browser, Open Source, HTML, C, auch Python, komplett Open Source,
mehrere Implement, mehrere Open Source Implementierungen, Sprachstandards, Standard Library, Referenzimplementierung,
Runtime, alles Open Source. Gut, SQL zählt jetzt nicht, Typescript, sogar Typescript, Microsoft-Zeug wieder, Bash,
schon seit jeher, Java mit Open JDK, auch C Sharp, .NET als Runtime, das, ähm, die Standard Library, die, die Sprache
an sich, kannst dir den Standard angucken, alles mögliche, komplett Open Source. C++ ist so ein, so ein Ding, muss man
sagen, theoretisch ist C++ Open Source, aber es gibt keine, es gibt keine offizielle Referenzimplementierung von
C++, es gibt GCC, was der Sache vielleicht am nächsten kommt, aber das ist halt nicht so wirklich die offizielle
Implementierung, bei C ist es ja genauso, aber die nennenswerten Compiler sind Open Source, sowohl für C++ als auch C.
Ich meine, es gibt, es gibt im Prinzip zwei nennenswerte, es gibt GCC und es gibt L, ich kann mir das immer nicht
merken, wie heißt das Projekt? LVM? LLVM? Nee, LLVM sind AI-Geschichten, LVM heißt das. Nee, doch, LLVM, Alter, also C, Clang
oder Clang, wie das manche aussprechen, also sind da im Prinzip die einzigen zwei wirklich nennenswerten, so größeren, größeren
C++-Compiler. Es gibt da noch für Microcontroller gibt's natürlich noch irgendwelche GCC-Extensions, beispielsweise
diese Extensa-Geschichte für den ESP32 und sowas, aber letztendlich, es gibt eigentlich LLVM und also CLang, Clang und GCC
und bei C ist es genauso, es ist das gleiche. So, PHP ist glaube ich auch komplett alles Open Source, Standard Library-Implementierung, drumherum
PowerShell, sogar fucking PowerShell ist Open Source, Go, komplett Open Source, Runtime, Standard, alles, ja, Rust von Anfang an, Kotlin, ich weiß es nicht, ich denke auch mal
Ruby von Anfang an, Lua, keine Ahnung, wer bist du verrückt, wir verwenden wirklich Lua, Dart auch, äh, das, lass mal aus, wo, Swift mittlerweile auch, R, weiß ich nicht
Ähm, WhistleBasic.net, sogar WhistleBasic.net, ähm, Matlab, das könnte tatsächlich sogar Close Source sein, das weiß ich nicht, Groovy auch, Delphi, keine Ahnung
Pearl auch, also, man sieht's, man sieht's, ja, ich glaube, ich habe den Point gemaked, jetzt. So, habe ich jetzt, habe ich eigentlich schon alles, alles rebooted und, und neu restarted
Updates gemacht, ich glaube schon, gucken wir mal kurz, ähm, Toolbox, oh, da gibt's jede Menge Zeug, Updating, ja, das müssen wir noch updaten lassen, also ViewNative gab's aber früher
Oh, gibt's das nicht mehr? ViewNative has been deprecated, MonkaW, oh ja, gut, dann halt nicht, dafür kannst, du kannst Quasar verwenden, wenn du View verwenden willst, das ist auch für sowas beliebt
Ich weiß nicht, ob es, ob es sowas wie SvelteKit Native gibt, keine Ahnung, okay, gibt's, gibt's anscheinend, aber es ist ja kein Ding, man kann einfach Elektron nehmen und dann kann man jedes JavaScript Framework benutzen, was man möchte, obwohl es nicht, dann nicht ganz so Native ist, wie der, wie der Rest, es hat halt immer noch einen Browser dazwischen
Was heißt hier eigentlich Visual Basics oder auch Open Source, ja, ist es, GitHub, VisualBasics.net, äh, dann muss ich da nach VB.net suchen, ist es nicht, ist es echt nicht, doch, ist es, also das gibt's, mal davon abgesehen, das ist, das ist aber halt nur die, der Standard, also das ist auf jeden Fall nicht der, der VB.source-Code
Okay, keine Ahnung, vielleicht ist das in irgendeinem .NET-Repo mit drinnen, das meiste UI-Zeug unter Linux ist halt absolut grausam, das Beste ist, das, das Beste, was sie, was sie zu bieten haben, ist tatsächlich Qt, das ist ein richtig nices Cross-Plattform-Framework, zumindest, zumindest was Desktop angeht, Qt und, Qt und Mobile weiß ich nicht, ob das so eine geile Sache ist
Ne, ich weiß es wirklich nicht und ich will es auch gar nicht wissen
Leute, während die Dinger update, ne, also die, die, die, die Spam-Bots, die Spam-Bots auf YouTube drehen wirklich langsam durch, ich hab letztens, okay, was letztens, vor, vor zwei Stunden oder so, war ich auf Twitter und da hat gerade der Lost, kennt bestimmt noch einer von früher, hat gerade der Lost ein neues Video gepostet von sich, das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an, keine Sorge, jetzt nix, was, was wir heute im Progress-Stream machen
So, und da hab ich mal so auf das Video draufgeklickt und das erste, was ich, immer noch, irgendwelche fucking Spam-Bots sind die einzigen, die am Start sind, man, das Fachwissen, das sie in diesem Video teilen, ist unglaublich bereichernd, ihr Ehrenamt hat sich als sehr nützlich erwiesen, ich sende ihnen meinen aufrichtigsten Dank
Ja, Camellia, was, Shirakawa, alles klar, so, seriously, garantiert kein Spam, what the fuck, alter, was zum, okay, ich glaube das war nicht Toss, ich glaube man hat nichts gesehen, aber, fuck man, YouTube, fucking shit
Moment, Moment Leute, ich muss mal kurz, ich muss mal kurz bei mir im anderen Browser angucken, ob man irgendwas gesehen hat, da muss ich den Bot löschen sonst, okay, man hat nix gesehen, man hat nix gesehen, die ist nur äußerst leicht bekleinert, aber man hat nichts gesehen, okay, ich muss den Bot nicht löschen, alles gut
Oh man, alter, dass sich da noch jemand dran erinnert, hat auch niemand gesehen, das stimmt wohl, das stimmt wohl, das stimmt wohl, auf Twitch ist es schlimmer
Letztens, wisst ihr noch, wo letztens irgendwie, wo ich umgeschaltet hab, Channels auf Deutsch und dann, das war ja nicht mal Poolstream, das war ja einfach so, Popo in die Kamera streamen, so hat das Ding jetzt geupdatet hier, ja, alles klar, okay, gut, dann können wir loslegen, würde ich sagen, wir haben noch zweieinhalb Stunden Zeit
Also, Mojolang, das probieren wir jetzt aus, Leute, ich hab legit, normalerweise hab ich mir im Vorfeld das immer ein bisschen angeguckt, ich hab echt gar keine Ahnung, ich weiß, das Einzige was ich davon weiß ist, dass man seine Dateien Punkt Fire Emoji nennen kann, man kann sie Punkt Mojo oder Punkt Fire Emoji nennen
Mit AI hat das ehrlich gesagt überhaupt nichts zu tun, es ist quasi Python, was man zu einem Single Binary kompilieren kann, das gibt es mehrere, ja, es gibt ja mal Python Compiler, aber die bieten zusätzlich noch mehr Sachen an, was quasi über das hinausgeht, was Python hat, bin ich mir nicht sicher, wie weit wir da heute kommen
Also, was ich mir heute mal angucken will, so ganz einfache Basics, wie kompiliert man ein Programm und dann, das ist ja für mich immer eine ganz wichtige Geschichte, dann bauen wir unseren Docker Container und gucken, wie rückwärtskompatibel die Binaries sind und wie self-contained die Binaries sind
Wenn da schöne, rückwärtskompatible, self-contained Binaries rauskommen, ist das immer eine super, super Geschichte für irgendwelche Tools intern, Tools für Admins oder sonst was, das ist immer ganz praktisch, ja, deswegen da ist Go absolut King, was das angeht, da gibt es nichts, was an Go rankommt
C-Sharp holt mit AOT-Kompilierung ein bisschen auf, leider haben sie immer noch ihre doofe Abhängigkeit mit glibc, das heißt, du musst dein .NET-Zeug auf einer ganz alten Plattform im Container kompilieren, dass es möglichst lange auf rückwirkend läuft, zum Beispiel, wenn du noch Red Hat 7 Systeme hast, dann läuft das nicht so ohne weiteres
Dann gucken wir uns an, wie groß die Binary-Size ist, dann gucken wir mal an, ob wir vielleicht C-Funktionen callen können daraus, weil das ist ja immerhin, sagen ja auch, ist für Low-Level-Sachen mit geeignet, gucken wir mal, wie groß ein Binary ist und was die so sagen, aber nachdem ich keine Ahnung habe, würde ich sagen, wir readen jetzt die Docs getting started
Get Mojo, also wir haben das beste Betriebssystem der Welt, dementsprechend ist das sicherlich schon in irgendeinem Repo zur Verfügung, Mojo-Idee, da gibt es eine eigene Idee für, das ist doch, das ist sicherlich was anderes
Okay, was bin ich hier? Okay, das ist das, gibt es das nicht? Soll ich mal nach Lang suchen? Wie, das gibt es nicht als, was ist denn das? Arch, by the way, ich bin schwer enttäuscht, ist das richtig, das gibt es nicht? Gibt es nicht als Aure oder irgendwas, das ist ja hochgradig fragwürdig
Auf der Arbeit muss ich demnächst was in C++ programmieren, das hat seine Vorteile, wenn du es damit machst, du ersparst dir dieses ganze rückwärtskompatibilitäts-Gelib-C-Geschiss, das ist wahrscheinlich sogar deutlich angenehmer, wenn das portable sein muss, das Binary am Ende
Leider hat Muzel so seine Probleme, was DNS-Anfragen angeht, beziehungsweise Linux mit Muzel als C-Standard-Library hat wohl Probleme bei DNS-Anfragen
Okay, wie installiert man das ganze jetzt? Getting started, download, das ist ja einfach, das muss ich mir jetzt mal angucken, also, Mojo-SDK includes everything you need for local Mojo development, including the Mojo-Standard-Library and the Mojo-Command-Line-Interface
Mojo-CLI can start rebel, das ist im Prinzip so eine Ausprobier-Command-Line, ich weiß gar nicht wofür das steht, repeat, einfügen, ausführen, repeat oder irgendwie sowas, keine Ahnung wofür das steht, das ist im Prinzip das, was man wenn man Python startet auch bekommt, so eine interaktive Command-Line, wo man das ausprobieren kann
Compile and run, we've also published a Mojo-Extension for Visual Studio Code, okay, anscheinend müssen wir Visual Studio Code read eval print loop, genau, das meine ich, hast du mal Python fast API ausprobiert, nein, ich habe allgemein relativ wenig in Python gemacht, ich glaube, das Größte, was ich in letzter Zeit in Python gemacht habe und das sollte schon für meine Python-Skills absolut bezeichnend sein, ist der Countdown für meine Leiste hier oben
Und er ist nicht so einfach, so ganz so billig, wie er aussieht, ja, man kann ihn starten, man kann ihn anhalten, man kann ihn wieder starten, man kann ihn resetten und man kann Stunden und Minuten setzen, wie man will, ja und dann wieder starten und wieder starten
Oh, war das, habe ich da gerade einen Bug gefunden, kann das sein? Ne, geht, das ist das Größte, was ich in Python in den letzten Jahren gemacht habe und dieser Timer hat, fragt mich nicht, 300 Zeilen Code oder so, das ist simpel, also ich habe keine großen Python-Erfahrungen und mit dem Ökosystem und den ganzen Libraries kenne ich mich tatsächlich nicht gut aus
Okay, jetzt habe ich den Kram runtergeladen, hier ist die Visual Studio Extension, Download, Setup Guide includes, okay, Setup Guide, wollt ihr mich veräppeln? Geht das unter Arch gar nicht? Dann ist sofort Rage Quit angesagt, sage ich euch, ich installiere mir kein Ubuntu, um das auszuprobieren, auch kein Ubuntu 4M, Download, ja, okay, let's go
Ich soll mich registrieren? Wollt ihr mich verarschen? Ne, gibt es nicht, gibt es nicht, ich, okay, okay, ich, also, bisher habe ich ja nur drüber gemeckert, dass es nicht Open Source ist, ja, aber, the fuck? Das ist doch nicht euer Ernst
Okay, ich mache mir einen Fake Account, ist okay, 10-Minute-Mail, pass mal auf, die haben Fake Accounts jetzt auch noch gesperrt, dann raste ich aus, ey, Jantari, danke für den Sub, ich raste aus, wenn die Fake Accounts gesperrt haben, ich dreh dich durch, ja, GitHub Actions, kannst du dann auch klicken, deswegen gibt es da auch kein Aua, wahrscheinlich, weil du es nicht distributen darfst, einfach so, ich sehe schon, das ist nichts
Ich glaube, die, ach, haben die allen Ernstes freie E-Mail, ich meine, es ist an sich kein Problem, ich habe genug, ich habe unendlich E-Mail-Adressen auf den ganzen Domains und die sind halt nicht, hä, ich, ich, der falsche Tab, wo ist der falsche Tab? Ja, ist egal, boah, das regt mich auf, okay
Warte mal, ich muss meine VM starten hier auf dem zweiten Bildschirm, oder habe ich die VM hier gar nicht mehr? Shit, ich habe meine andere VM hier gar nicht mehr? No, aber ich glaube, ich, ah doch, ich kann mich im Web-Interface für meine Domain und E-Mails einloggen, äh, Chat, warte mal, ich muss mal kurz, ja, ja, Oracle-VM-Kappa-0.0, ach, es nervt nicht
Ich will jetzt copy-pasten, okay, Oracle-VM-Kappa-0.0, jetzt muss ich nur noch das Web-Interface dafür aufmachen, ach, da ist es, nice, okay, es hat einfach nur gedauert, es hat einfach nur gedauert, hat sich alles erledigt
So, Dark-Reader aus, uah, Auge, wupp, Lords, Modular-Project, ehrlich gesagt juckt mich Mojo, so, Company-Name, Check W, wir haben über 5000 Leute, ist immer mal realistisch, Twitch-Chat zählt mit, Industrie sind für, ja, alternative Medizin, Check Alu
Oh, Leute, ich will nicht wissen, was die letzten Tage auf Twitter los gewesen sind, ich hab die letzten Tage auf Twitter ein bisschen gemieden, als ich gehört hab, dass beim Medizin-Nobelpreis jemand oder zwei Leute gewonnen haben, die an der Corona, ähm, an Corona-Medizin mitgeforscht haben, da war bestimmt massive, massivstes Check Alu angesagt auf Twitter, massivstes Check Alu
Say good day to Z-Bock, ha, ha, ha, hier sieht man auch ein paar andere, die sich eingeloggt haben mit Fake-E-Mail-Adresse, ha, ha, ha, mal ganz davon abgesehen, ich finde das sehr MonkaDSGVO, dass die irgendwelche E-Mail-Adressen leaken von random Leuten, das ist mit Sicherheit sehr MonkaDSGVO
Okay, skip, darf ich sie jetzt downloaden? Och nee, das ist wirklich Debian-Only, wirklich, es muss Ubuntu 2004 sein, okay, ich mach mal, ich mach mal ne Snapshot, mach mal ne Snapshot vorher, take Snapshot, da werden wahrscheinlich random User E-Mail-Adressen geleakt, ja
Willst du ja selbst, nee, okay, Snapshot, das ist der aktuelle Snapshot, den alten können wir mal deleten, den brauchen wir nicht mehr, mach doch fix ne Hetzner-VM, wofür brauch ich ne Hetzner-VM, ich will mich da connecten drauf, mit nem grafischen Editor, da kann man das sicherlich auch irgendwie remote machen, aber das macht's ja unnötig kompliziert, ich kann mir einfach einen lokalen Ubuntu-VM machen, aber ich will keine Ubuntu-VM machen
Ich weiß jetzt schon, dass ich das nie verwenden werde, wenn ich, nur um die Sprache verwenden zu können, ein Ubuntu brauche, nicht, dass ich was prinzipiell gegen Ubuntu hätte, ich fände das eine ganz brauchbare Distribution, aber ich will nicht
Meine Qt-VM, die müsste eigentlich mal wieder rausgeholt werden
Was willst du denn, Paul Cummings, weiß ich ja noch nicht, irgendwas, musst du mal ausprobieren, ist das, hab ich grad meinen AP-Key geleakt, kann das sein, ist das, ist das AP-Key-Leak
Nein, Gott, nein, Gott, bitte, nein, nein, nein, nein
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ich bin nicht wütend, ich seh es nicht ein, dass ich das use jemals unter den, welche Linux-Distribution würdest du mir fürs Studium empfehlen, eine Einsteiger-Distribution, mit der du einfach arbeiten kannst, dann nimm sowas wie Mint, oder suchst du fürs Studium eine Linux-VM, in der du dich austoben kannst und Linux lernen
Das ist die Frage, wenn du eine, wenn du eine VM suchst, die du, wo du Linux lernen kannst mit, Arch by the way, ich mein, das wird dich erstmal ein bisschen zur Verzweiflung bringen, machst du eine Arch-Minimal-Installation und dann richtest du dir mal den ganzen Kram ein, von grafischer Oberfläche angefangen, das brauchst du übrigens gar keinen Laptop oder so für zu opfern, einfach, einfach VM, so wie ich hier
Und dann kannst du dich damit auseinandersetzen, dann hast du auf jeden Fall einiges gelernt, was Command-Line-Handling, Command-Line-Tools und alles mögliche angeht, wo Config-Dateien liegen, es wird dich aber, es wird dich auch ein bisschen zur Verzweiflung bringen, das heißt, wahrscheinlich ist es besser, wenn du ganz anfängst, tatsächlich installier dir eine Linux-Mint in einer VM und benutzt das täglich, das ist fast wichtiger, als das von Hand, Ubuntu ist auch fein, ja, ist vollkommen okay
Aber das Beste ist, benutze es, ne, WSL ist kein richtig guter Ersatz, wir hatten doch letztens mal wieder irgendein Thema, was nicht richtig funktioniert unter WSL, WSL ist so eine Krücke, wenn man, wenn die Arbeit sagt, du darfst kein Linux verwenden, obwohl du Linux-Admin bist und hast WSL, kannst du die Sandbox nutzen, vielleicht, aber damit kann ich nicht ausprobieren, wie sich das in Containern und rückwärts kompatibel und so, ne, ne
Da hab ich echt keinen Bock drauf, also ganz ehrlich, Zwangsregistrierung dafür ist dämlich, Ubuntu-only ist dämlich, kein Bock drauf
Also das Wichtigste ist fast ohne Mist, dass du das benutzt, versuch es einfach zu benutzen, du kannst Ubuntu verwenden, du kannst auch Linux-Mint verwenden, du kannst irgendwas verwenden, ist eigentlich wurscht, du musst nicht gleich in Arch dir selbst aufsetzen
Linux-Mint ist dann eine schöne Einsteiger-Diskussion, wo alles fix und fertig ist, wichtig ist, dass du es benutzt, versuch das für tägliche Aufgaben zu benutzen, also wenn du im Internet surfst, wenn du, was auch immer du machen willst, natürlich, wenn du jetzt sagen willst, ey ich will unbedingt auf Steam was spielen, dann mach das lieber unter Windows, weil gerade mit Linux-Mint, Vm ist dann mit Spielen nicht viel
Ich würde dir auf jeden Fall Vmware empfehlen und Vmware Workstation würde ich dir tatsächlich empfehlen, weil du bekommst in Vmware Workstation Key schon für den ablohnenden Alper Keyshops hinterhergeschmissen oder du googelst mal, was natürlich nicht erlaubt ist, also ich hab es mir damals gekauft bei einem Keyshop, ja
Aber wichtig ist, dass du es benutzt und wenn es Probleme gibt, dann musst du dich auch ein bisschen damit auseinandersetzen, wo liegt welche Config-Datei im Heimatverzeichnis und wie kriege ich es zum Laufen und wie customize ich meine Shell und sowas, versuch aber erst gar nicht und das ist jetzt auch ein Tipp, den ich jetzt, jemand der sich wirklich ernsthaft damit auseinandersetzen will, versuch nicht die Kommandozeile zu umgehen, das kannst du vielleicht so dem 0815 User raten, so nach dem Motto, ja man kann unter Linux-Mint auch das quasi fast alles über GUI machen und so
Aber du wirst früher oder später feststellen, das ist gar kein Nachteil, weil die Leute verbinden das mit diesem beschissenen CMD-Prompt von Windows, das ist gar kein Nachteil, das ist eigentlich eines der größten Vorteile, die du unter Linux hast, dass du eine ordentliche Kommandozeile hast und auch jede Menge ordentlichen Terminals
Ja, aber das funktioniert in der VM doch nicht richtig, also Spielen unter Linux ist je nach Spiel eh schon nicht so dolle, geht mittlerweile viel, aber gerade in der VM kannst du es vergessen, nur Kommandozeile, okay das ist die Hardcore-Variante, ja, ja, ja
Was du auch unbedingt brauchst, essenziell, wenn du Linux verwendest, sind die White-People-Happy-Desktop-Backgrounds und vor allem der Nudel mit Lachs, der ist sehr wichtig
Eskel-Stream, Donald Dump, Dankeschön für den Sub, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, ich mach keine, ich mach keine, vergiss es, Stellenanzeigen, wenn du eine hast, schick her, jetzt hab ich jetzt eigentlich keinen, will ich nicht den ganzen Abend mit verbringen, der VM-Champ ist für Kommandozeilensachen
Was für ein Terminal verwendest du? Das hier, ReactOS, haben wir doch schon mal, ist da nicht die Entwicklung mehr oder weniger zum Erliegen gekommen? Also, ich verwende als Terminal West-Term, ja, West-Term, GitHub, was da?
Das mag jetzt erstmal vielleicht etwas sehr abgedreht aussehen von der Konfiguration her, weil, die haben nicht einfach eine Konfigurationsdatei, ich hab sie sogar noch in der History, die haben nicht einfach eine Konfigurationsdatei fürs Terminal, nein, die haben komplett Lua integriert in das Terminal
Das heißt, du kannst im Prinzip schon das Ganze so verwenden, wie eine normale Konfig-Datei, siehst ja hier, guck, so relativ, relativ normale Konfig-Datei, Key ist gleich irgendwas und, und, äh, Window, Transparency, Opacity, Background, Colors, Hyper-GS als Schrott
Also, du kannst es mehr oder weniger verwenden, wie, wie mit einer normalen Konfig-Datei, aber, das richtig Geile ist, ich hab auch erst gesagt, wozu brauche ich Lua komplett in meinem Terminal, ist doch komplett unsinnig, komplett overrated, outdated, debated, aber ich zeige euch jetzt mal was, was ihr so in anderen Terminals nicht machen könnt, und zwar, das hier
Das ist sicherlich nicht die eleganteste Art und Weise, das zu lösen, aber, ich kann sagen, okay, wir binden den mittleren Mausbutton und den, das stimmt übrigens gar nicht, was ich hier erzähle, äh, wir binden den rechten Mausbutton, also hier, Event, Down, äh, rechter, rechter, rechter Maustaste, so, wir binden den rechten, den rechten Mausbutton auf folgendes, so
So, und das ist, das ist tatsächlich eine sehr coole Sache, guck mal, wenn ich jetzt hier was anklicke mit der rechten Maustaste, wenn ich normal die rechte Maustaste drücke, dann pastet es, wenn ich was markiert habe und die rechte Maustaste drücke, dann copiet es, entfernt die Selection und wenn ich jetzt wieder die rechte Maustaste drücke, dann pastet es wieder
Und das funktioniert anhand dieser Logik hier, guckt, der schaut, wenn die rechte Maustaste gedrückt wird, gibt es im aktuellen Window eine Selection, so, oder ist die Selection leer, wenn es, wenn es eine Selection gibt, dann kopiere die Selection in das Clipboard und in die Primary Selection von, von dem aktuell ausgewählten Split und dann macht die Selection weg
Wenn es keine Selection gibt, dann soll die rechte Maustaste als Paste fungieren, also sprich, man kann selbst sich hier in der Config programmieren, wie Copy Paste funktionieren soll und ich kann jetzt im Prinzip, wenn ich Copy Pasten will, also mal angenommen, ich will das hier Copy Pasten mit der Maus, ich klicke das an, drücke rechts, rechts und schon ist es da, mittlere Maustaste geht übrigens auch
Und das ist einfach nice, dass das funktioniert, ich habe noch ein paar andere, paar andere Kleinigkeiten gemacht, aber ansonsten, ich habe das Farbschema ein bisschen angepasst, aber ansonsten nichts, nichts großartiges, das finde ich aber wirklich extrem, extremely nice bei dem Terminal, dazu kommt, es ist sehr geschwind, aber es ist wirklich sehr zackig
Also guck mal, wenn es ein Terminal schafft, 50% CPU Auslastung auf allen Cores zu generieren, kannst du von ausgehen, es ist blazingly fast written in Rust und es ist tatsächlich written in Rust, aber das ist nicht der Grund, warum ich es verwende, also es ist nice, das Terminal
Und du brauchst kein TMAX mehr, du kannst komplett in West Term so Sachen machen, wie Horizontal Splitten, Vertikal Splitten und sagen wir mal, hier unten starte ich jetzt das da, hier oben starte ich, habe ich Hollywood noch drauf, ne habe ich nicht, hier oben lasse ich das laufen und hier unten, keine Ahnung, Watch LS-LA, so und dann kann ich es gleich wie in TMAX machen, kann ich das hier ranzoomen und wieder reinzoomen und sowas
Also du brauchst und du kannst auch Panels switchen, du kannst auch Tabs machen, im Prinzip brauchst du lokal kein TMAX mehr, was ich enorm praktisch finde, weil sonst hast du manchmal das Problem, dass du TMAX in TMAX verwendest
Also du startest ja oftmals über SSH, du startest eine TMAX Session, machst vielleicht Session Sharing mit irgendeinem Kollege auf der Arbeit, aber dann hast du irgendwann TMAX in TMAX, da musst du dann immer so Doppel-Escape, da musst du CTRL-B, CTRL-B, C und sowas drücken, um auf dem Server was zu machen, so wenn du einen Terminal hast, wo du lokal alles splitten und aufteilen kannst, wie du willst, mehrere Tabs machen, wunderbar und auf dem Server dann TMAX starten, das ist die perfekte Kombi, wie ich finde
Also das ist echt ein Terminal, weiß nicht, ob man das Geheimtipp nennen kann, ich meine, das hat immerhin 10.500 Sterne auf ShitHub, ist ja sicherlich nicht klein, achja, und wisst ihr, wisst ihr, Leute, Chat-Game, Chat-Game, hab ich ja ganz vergessen, wisst ihr, was das beste Feature von diesem Terminal ist?
Das, was sonst kaum ein Terminal kann, es kann animierte GIFs anzeigen, direkt im Terminal, also das sollte ja nur wirklich, das sollte ja nur wirklich jeden überzeugen, oder? Wie das heißt, nein, West Term, das vereint so das Beste aus so allen anderen Terminals, die ich kenne
Kann man damit Shrek angucken? Also wenn du Shrek als GIF hast, ich weiß nicht, was die für Formate unterstützen, ich weiß nicht, was die für Formate unterstützen, vielleicht sagen die uns das ja
Name of the image displayed, also ich hab keine Ahnung, was die für Formate unterstützen, aber nachdem die wahrscheinlich kein H264 unterstützen, guck mal, hier haben wir keckel-web-p, es kommt sogar mit web-p aus, oder liegt das an dem, was ich gescriptet hab, dass es web-p kann?
Ah, if svg, nee, nee, das kann web-p abspielen direkt, ich mein, es hat ein paar, hat vielleicht ein paar kleine Grafik-Glitches, aber immerhin, web-p im Terminal, nicht schlecht, ja, also ich kann das, kann das Terminal wirklich nur empfehlen, sollte sich jeder mal angucken, der gerne auf der Konsole arbeitet
Snap ist Hyper-Müll, ich bin mittlerweile 39, Shrek als GIF? Seriously? Ernsthaft? Es hat irgendjemand Shrek als GIF? Ist das MonkaToss, wenn man sowas runterlädt? Preview Reddit? Shrek als GIF? Wie groß ist denn das? Oh, schon fertig, 23 MB, okay
ImageCat? Oh, ich glaube, das hat Probleme mit dem Dateinamen, keckel-3.gif, das kann's nicht, das ist kaputt, das funktioniert nicht, kein Shrek im Terminal, oder ist das einfach zu klein, dass es das nicht richtig anzeigen kann?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, mein Terminal, oh shit, die VRM crasht halb, Moment, da gibt es wirklich Shrek als GIF? Alter, die Leute, man, kick, alter, okay, mal gucken, mal gucken, ob das geht, hey, das funktioniert, Shrek im Terminal
Jetzt müsst ihr nur noch gucken, ob man hier irgendwie die Geschwindigkeit einstellen könnte, aber das geht, glaube ich, nicht, ich glaube, also, wenn das MonkaToss ist, dann weiß ich auch nicht, aber warum funktioniert das andere nicht, außer, dass mein Rechner voll am abkacken ist?
Könnte das an der Höhe und so liegen, dass man dann sagen muss, hier mal, minus, minus, width, 80, 80, 80, das vielleicht, so, naja, das funktioniert, aber das andere funktioniert, ich bin begeistert, Shrek im Terminal, nice, MonkaToss, nicht, dass es einfach die Reddit-Page runter, ah, du hast recht, du hast recht, du hast recht, warte mal
Moment, das ist ein MP4? Hä? Es ist überhaupt kein GIF, es ist ein super klein skaliertes MP4, beziehungsweise, Moment, MP4 kann ja, ähm, FF, FF Probe, es ist, ja, das H264, ja, kein Wunder, dass das nicht im Terminal abgespielt werden kann
Ich meine, ich könnte meinen Player erweitern, ja, also, ich habe ja hier auch schon was gescriptet, wenn es SVG ist, wenn es SVG ist, wird das durch Image, Image-Pipe durchgejagt, also, ich könnte das theoretisch auch in ein, in ein GIF umwandeln mit FFmpeg und dann abspielbar machen, hier in diesem Script, aber ich will's, ich will's jetzt ja nicht, das hat Reddit re-encoded, ja, so sieht's aus
Ja, also, mit, mit FFmpeg müsste das so funktionieren, wir probieren das mal aus, FFmpeg, jetzt kommt FFmpeg-Magic, wir haben ja sonst heute nix, wir haben ja auch nix besseres zu tun, ja, dann nennen wir das mal um, keckel3.gif, keckel3.mp4, so, FFmpeg, bin ich mal gespannt hier, keckel3.mp3, so, jetzt holt er sich das erste, guck mal, ob das funktioniert
Oh, shit!
100% CPU-Loss!
Okay, okay, track mp4, vielleicht keine so gute Idee gewesen
Ähm, äh, GIF, okay, no chance, keine Chance, Leute, keine Chance, das kriegen wir, vergiss es, hey, wait a minute, das, ich, immerhin, immerhin
Wir machen mal, wir machen das mal kurz weg, test.gif, äh, okay, mal gucken, mal gucken, mal gucken, ob es VLC abspielen kann, ist das allen Ernstes ein 30x30, 60x60 GIF-encoded von Shrek, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, wie, wie groß ist das?
Ups, das ist einfach fast schon GIF-groß mittlerweile, als GIF-encoded, und der hat erst 30 Minuten, wie lange ist denn das? Eineinhalb Stunden, ne? Das ist am Ende 3 GIF-groß, okay, das wird es nicht abspielen können, das glaube ich nicht, das glaube ich nicht, dass er das am Ende abspielen kann, der wird, der wird, der wird doch kein, der lädt doch kein GIF irgendwie mit, mit 3 GIF-Größe
Naja, gucken wir mal weiter hier, okay, irgendjemand, der wollte, dass ich mir eine Stellenanzeige angucke, hast du es mittlerweile gepostet? Ich habe es nicht gesehen, habt ihr private Daten in der Cloud? Ich habe mein Steuerzeug bei Google Drive liegen, weil ich den Ordner mit meinem Steuerberater geshared habe, wann machst du den Wahl-O-Mat?
Ich denke mal am Freitag, Freitag, Samstag, Sonntag ist Wahl in Hessen, das sagt mir nix, ne, sagt mir nix, haben wir denn, haben wir noch irgendwas, irgendwas Spannendes auf YouTube, was wir uns, was wir uns angucken können? Erklärungsversuche, Abenteuer-Hochschritte, Unities lächerliche Entschuldigung, das gucken wir uns an, wir haben uns nämlich letztens von Sam schon angeguckt, das Video über diesen Schwachsinn von Unity, das Aus für Unity
Wir gucken uns nochmal an, was er über diesen Unity Apology Post sagt, ich finde es auch komplett lächerlich, im Prinzip haben die eigentlich nur gesagt, so nach dem Motto, ist doch gar nicht so schlimm, ist ja trotzdem alle gefickt, aber ist doch gar nicht so schlimm
Was ist denn Viddy? Habe ich noch nie gehört, was ist Fiddy oder Fiddy? Fiddy, die suchen wir mal, Fiddy, hoffentlich kann man danach suchen ohne Monka, du meinst wahrscheinlich das hier, oder?
A modern watch command, oh nein, oh nein, written in rust, nicht wieder irgendwas sinnlos, rewritten in rust, go, ah ok, written in go, naja gut, ja aber, also warum, warum exactly muss man watch replacen?
Ok, was kann es denn mehr, außer irgendwie komische Dinger, ah man hat History Ausgaben von watch, ok, das kommt da schon bei mir an, ja schlimm, das ist nicht schlecht, normalerweise sage ich ja diese ganzen Tool Rewrites sind meistens so für die hohle Hand, man wollte halt irgendeine mal ausprobieren
Oh shit, meine VM, man, lädt das jetzt wirklich alles in RAM gerade? Ja, ja, ja, Leute, das lädt das komplette GIF in RAM, guck mal, es hat schon 2 GB im RAM, gleich gehts los, zum Glück habe ich 24 GB RAM in der VM
Oh ne, es ist gecrashed, shit, ja das wird, das wird wohl nix, ah Moment, ich habe ja, habe ich gar nicht mehr, naja es ist, es crashed, das finde ich aber cool, ne History, wie gesagt, normalerweise bin ich ja der Meinung, dieses Rewrite, wir rewriten alles in rust, einfach weil wir es können, ist relativ sinnlos
Aber das hier finde ich in der Tat ganz cool, weil du eine History von den Commands hast, das ist praktisch, weil oftmals machst du ein Watch auf irgendwas und denkst, was, was, was war da gerade? Und dann siehst du es nicht mehr, also die History finde ich cool, das ist, das ist wirklich nice
Ob, das, das dumme ist, dort wo man es braucht, ja, also auf irgendeinem Linux Server, ist es nicht drauf, das heißt man müsste das Kommando quasi über SSH starten und dann vidi lokal benutzen, aber, aber nice, finde ich, gefällt mir, das ist nice, ja
Das kenne ich, das kenne ich, das kenne ich, man kann da auch bestimmt mit Docker inspect vieles machen, aber das kenne ich, das hier kenne ich, das habe ich sogar auf der Arbeit schon mal vor, vor, äh, weiß ich nicht, noch gar nicht so langer Zeit, so zwei, drei Wochen, verwendet, um zu gucken, wie ein 3rd Party Hersteller seine Container gebaut hat, kann man sich nämlich die verschiedenen Layer angucken, von einem Docker Container, ja, das ist sehr praktisch, aber das, das kenne ich schon
Leute, heute ist doch Tag der Deutschen Einheit, ne, wo ist, wo ist eigentlich der, der, der Thorsten meldet sich zurück, wo ist denn der Osten heute, ich habe den, ich habe den vorhin angeschrieben in Discord, wo ist denn der Frasier, lasst mich mal kurz in Discord gucken, ob er geantwortet hat, wenn ja und er online ist, zerre ich den jetzt hier im Stream, aber ich glaube nicht, dass er da ist, ne, er ist nicht da, Sätke, Saatke
Kein Frasier am Start, na gut, man braucht RAM, also wofür man so viel RAM in der VM braucht, kann ich dir ganz einfach beantworten, weil man es viel zu sehr übertrieben hat mit seinem Rechner und der RAM Ausstattung, guck mal, ich habe, ich habe 64 GB RAM im Rechner und ich habe schon wirklich großzügig Tabs offen, mehrfach, ich habe eine VM in 24 GB und ich habe trotzdem gerade mal die Hälfte knapp von meinem RAM belegt,
also ein bisschen mehr als die Hälfte, deswegen kann man seiner VM 24 GB geben, wenn man sinnloserweise so viel RAM im Rechner eingebaut hat, weird flex, ich habe meine SSD mit einem Magnet geschrottet, wie soll das funktionieren, also der einzige Weg eine SSD mit Magnet zu schrotten, fällt mir ein, es ist halt ein paar Kilo schwerer Magnet und den hast du so aus 2 Meter Höhe drauf fallen lassen, ansonsten fällt mir da nichts, fällt mir da nichts ein,
wenn der Magnet nicht so schwer ist, dass er die SSD physisch zerstört, du hast ja meistens noch nicht mal bei Festplatten ein Problem, wenn du da einfach nur mal in die Nähe mit irgendeinem Magnet kommst, das war ja so ein Gerücht früher so, oh, Magnet rangehalten, Festplatte, mag vielleicht bei den ganz alten so gewesen sein, der war schon eine ganze Weile nicht mehr so, ByteSwap, das heißt, du hattest vorher Windows drauf, jetzt hast du Linux drauf, also glaube ich nicht, dass es am Magnet liegt, dass deine SSD kaputt ist,
ich glaube, du hast die eher in die Kontakte irgendwo geschrammt von deiner M2 SSD oder irgendwas, das kann man nicht vorstellen, dass das am Magnet lag, flickt, SATA SSD, Max, kennst du für ZSH und MacOS gute Themes, ich kann dir ein gutes ZSH Theme geben, aber das ist ja nicht MacOS spezifisch, du kannst meins verwenden, das ist Starship mit, Starship mit,
dieser Config, sieht dann so aus, ah, du kannst sogar Repos, du bekommst sogar angezeigt, was das Ding für eine .NET Version hat, was du installiert hast und was du targetest, das Feuer ist schon, was macht eigentlich Alpha 4 Games, lange nichts mehr,
nein, gibt nichts Neues, doch, warte mal, vor einem Tag, Hyenas, alter, dieses Game, das hat doch nie jemand interessiert und jetzt wurde es eingestellt, das habe ich auch mitgekriegt, wo ich mir denke, so, äh, war mitzurechnen, oder?
Lass mich mal kurz rebooten, ja, beste, immer schön starren alles auf, auf ShitHub, scheiße, ich spiele ja letzter Tag, huge Erfolg, würde ich sagen, das hat schon seinen Grund, warum das eingestellt wurde, morgen erst der Arbeitstag, als was?
Hattest du schon mal gespoilert, als was du anfängst? Ich meine, unter, unter Five, Fivehead Senior Windows Architekt, ist ja da wahrscheinlich nichts, sehr, sehr nice, Bock, lass mich raten, du hast dein PoE Tool published, Java Software Engineer, Richtung Software Architekt, siehste, war ich doch gar nicht so verkehrt,
nice, excellent, dann ist am Morgen richtig Java Hackermans angesagt, würde ich sagen, ich hatte irgendwo auch ein Java Emote, aber ich finde es nicht, doch, jetzt, kannst du mal das .files Repo updaten, kann ich, aber da hat sich so gut wie nichts dran geändert, nicht viel, dann lass uns doch mal ein kurzes Video noch angucken, wir haben ja heute eh nichts großartiges mehr vor,
weil es Mojo so verkackt hat, wir gucken, Unitys lächerliche Entschuldigung, okay, let's go, bisschen Drama ist immer, immer nice, zumal Unitys auch so mega verkackt hat und die Entschuldigung auch so lächerlich ist, dass ich, dass ich ihn fast schon wünschen würde, einfach, dass sie jetzt abkacken, ihr müsst euch mal vorstellen, ja, Unity, bei Unity gab es eine Bombendrohung, ich weiß nicht, wie weit ihr das mitgekriegt habt,
kurz nach dieser Ankündigung, dass Unity beispielsweise, gab ja viele Sachen, also im Kern war die Ankündigung von Unity, ab 01.01.2024 müssen, ausgewertet kann das übrigens nur von Unity werden, müssen Entwickler retroaktiv auch für schon veröffentliche Spiele beim Überschreiten einer gewissen Schwelle Geld bezahlen
und das rausfinden pro, wohlgemerkt, pro Installation Geld bezahlen, nicht irgendwie pro Verkäufe, pro Installation und rausfinden kann das Ganze nur Unity selbst, weil es keine öffentlichen Metriken dafür gibt und das Ganze ist retroaktiv, das heißt, hat jemand 2013 ein Spiel veröffentlicht und es installieren sich jetzt einfach Leute aus ihrer Steam-Datenbank, das Spiel wieder, muss der Geld bezahlen,
so, also, richtig, richtig für den Arsch und Unity hat sich jetzt entschuldigt und hat, ich weiß das Statement nicht mehr genau, hat irgendwie was erzählt, so, sorry, ihr habt es falsch verstanden, aber eigentlich ist es so, wie gesagt, ich hoffe ja, Unity versucht das beim Game Pass durchzusetzen, da müsste das Microsoft bezahlen und Microsoft wird einen Scheiß tun, an Unity Geld zu bezahlen,
nur, ja, das ist Unity erstmal egal, die warten einfach drauf, ob sich die Leute wehren und wehre dich mal als kleiner, kleiner Entwickler, wenn Unity ankommt, wir wollen Geld von dir, dann kannst du einfach mal nicht bezahlen, dann sagen, du darfst unsere Engine nicht mehr benutzen, die sitzen da wahrscheinlich am längeren Hebel, das Beste ist wahrscheinlich echt einfach sich von Unity vom Acker zu machen,
am Morgen wieder zwei Wochen Schule, ich checke nichts mit Subnetting, warum nicht, nimm IP-Calc, guck, IP-Calc, easy, beste, das hier, IP-Calc, das ist der IP-Calc, oh, vielleicht 16, da zeichnet er ja auch genau an, so, bla, bla, so sieht es aus, guck mal, sogar ein Binary Representation, das kann übrigens noch viel mehr IP-Calc,
HTML-Mode not supported, was, HTML, Moment, das kenne ich noch gar nicht, hier tab, IP-Calc, oh, ne, ich habe das laggy, Mist, Leute, ich habe das laggy Kernel gestartet und nicht den LTS, fuck, Version, ok,
Minus HTML, Minus, Minus HTML, tatsächlich, oh, keckel.html, Firefox, ok, warum nicht, braucht zwar kein Mensch, aber, oh, huge, ja, so, und du kannst ja noch viel mehr dir anzeigen lassen, die Hälfte steht da gefühlt gar nicht drin, ja, genau,
von bis kannst du direkt, Minus, Minus Split, also das ist sehr praktisch, wenn du, du kannst ja auch sowas sagen wie Slash 27 zum Beispiel, dann zeigt er dir genau an von, ups, jetzt habe ich wieder HTML drin, von was bis, also von wo bis wo, das anfängt und wie gesagt mit Minus S kannst du dann auch irgendwie splitten lassen in 15, 16 oder sowas, genau, also es ist sehr praktisch das Ding.
Ich mache jetzt erst nochmal den Chat durch, sonst bin ich wieder hoffnungslos hinten dran, ja, genau, also es gab, es gab bei Unity eine Bombendrohung nach diesen Ankündigungen und dann hat sich rausgestellt, das kam von einem eigenen Unity Mitarbeiter, also selbst die Mitarbeiter finden das scheiße, coole Tab-Leiste, meinst du die hier, da geht was, ja, dann wünschen wir dir alle hier Geld, Chat, wir wünschen dem Captain Poggers viel Erfolg morgen auf seiner neuen Arbeit.
Ihr müsst jetzt einmal alle oder es wäre sehr schön, wenn ihr euren Support zeigt mit einmal Mod-Check im, einmal Mod-Check im Chat für den Captain Poggers als neuer Senior Solution Java 5Head Architekt.
Marke Brech, danke für den Sub, sehr schön, das war das letzte Mal, aber noch anders, vielleicht haben sie das jetzt ja mal klargestellt, aber nach wie vor du kannst es nicht nachvollziehen, weil nur Unity die Metriken hat, das auch schon komplett affig ist.
SilentPain, danke für den Sub, exzellente Subscriptions, Leute, das ist sehr, wie würdest du jemandem wie zum Beispiel deinen Großeltern erklären, was du beruflich machst, sag ich mach was mit Computer, mehr ist dann eh, die Mühe vergeben, vergebens, ja, Hopfen und Malz verloren, sag du machst was mit Computer, mehr kannst du da wahrscheinlich nicht machen.
Es sei denn, du weißt, dass deine Großeltern irgendwie ein bisschen technikaffin sind, was die wenigsten sind, da kannst du vielleicht ein bisschen mehr erklären, aber sag du machst was mit Computer, tu dir den Stress, sie haben das versuchen zu erklären, weil dann, wenn du versuchst es zu erklären, dann sagt dein Opa sowas wie, ach und damit kann man heutzutage Geld verdienen oder irgendwie sowas Blödes, also sag du machst was mit Computer und Gutes.
Ist es normal, dass Netzwerklehrer manchmal komisch drauf sind? Generell sind Berufsschullehrer komisch drauf, niemand hat Bock Berufsschullehrer zu sein.
Ja gut, kommt drauf an, was er gemacht hat, aber Berufsschule ist eh für den Arsch, richtig reudig, Alter, Berufsschule, so richtig unsinnig, also dafür, der große Vorteil von Berufsschule ist, es ist, easy as fuck, extremely easy as fuck, ist Berufsschule, also ganz ehrlich, wer da Fünfer und Sechser schreibt, dem ist echt nicht mehr zu helfen.
Haben wir any Fünfer und Sechser Schreiber in der Berufsschule hier, dass ich euch mal öffentlich auf Twitch im Chat flamen kann? Nein, ich flame hier keinen, ich kenne auch Fünfer und Sechser Schreiber in der Berufsschule, aber Berufsschule ist wirklich so kack einfach gewesen, das konnte ich nicht verstehen, ja zu Recht wahrscheinlich.
Gut, dann gucken wir uns mal an, was gibt es denn Neues von Unity, beziehungsweise was sagt Samp zur Unity Entschuldigung, außer dass sie lächerlich ist, die ich ja auch schon gesagt habe.
Es ist ja, ich muss jetzt mal kurz stoppen, ja, ich finde es ja mittlerweile so hochgradig lächerlich mittlerweile, was generell so in der Gaming Branche abgeht, es ist ja bei vielen Releases schon der Entschuldigungsbrief geschrieben, bevor das Game rauskommt.
Ist euch mal aufgefallen, dass die letzten 1-2 Jahre diese Anzahl an Entschuldigungsposts enorm zugenommen hat, gefühlt bei jedem Release, was nicht so richtig läuft, kommt irgendein Entschuldigungsbrief hinterher.
Der lächerlichste Entschuldigungsbrief, wisst ihr, wisst ihr, was der lächerlichste Entschuldigungsbrief war überhaupt, Moment, Herr der Ringe, da müsst ihr jetzt durch, Gollum, Apology.
Die haben einfach schon gewusst, dass das Spiel scheiße ankommt und haben quasi schon ein Apology Letter im Vorfeld fertig geschrieben, dass sie den publischen können, weil sie eh schon wussten, dass das Game kacke ankommt.
Fazit daraus ist, das Studio wird keine eigenen Spiele mehr entwickeln.
Once again, we deeply apologize.
Ich weiß echt nicht mehr, was ich da blöder finden soll, dass die Spiele heutzutage so unfertig rauskommen oder dieses ganze Apologizen für jeden Scheiß.
Ihr müsst nicht Apologizen, wenn ihr einfach gescheites fertiges Spiel rausbringen würdet.
Und wenn ihr gescheites fertiges Spiel rausbringt, dann ist es scheiße.
Shit happens, man. Das wird nicht besser dadurch, dass sich einer wild Apologized dafür.
Am besten ist, die würden sich Apologizen, indem sie ein gutes Spiel rausmachen.
Zum Beispiel, guckt euch Cyberpunk an, das ist jetzt ganz gut geworden, guckt euch Dings an, nicht Star Citizen, No Man's Sky.
So, ja, so Apologize dich richtig bei der Community.
Machst halt ein gescheites Game raus, aber nein, die haben so...
Vor allem gibt es doch irgendwo auf dieser Welt einen Marketing Apology Generator.
Das ist immer exakt der gleiche Mist, was da drin stehen.
I allow you to enjoy the game to its fullest potential.
Hat das überhaupt mal Patches bekommen?
Okay, warte mal, Steam, Herr der Ringe, Gollum.
Wir gucken jetzt Patch History an.
Wie die Screenshots einfach auch schon kacke aussehen.
Und die Screenshots ja im Prinzip immer mit das Beste sein sollen, was das Game nennt.
Also, Moment, wo ist denn die Patch History?
Das finde ich immer auf Update History, okay.
Major Patch.
Moment, es gab einen Patch?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Einen ganzen Patch?
Kann das sein?
Ja, die können nix mehr patchen, aber da sieht man mal, wie viel man auf diese komischen Apology Letter schon geben kann.
Jetzt ist das Game halt perfekt, ein Patch.
Ich find's so affig, diese ganzen Praktiken da drumherum.
Okay, jetzt gucken wir uns mal das Video an.
Der sieht echt so aus, als ist er einmal vor die Wand gelaufen, oder?
Pro weiterer Installation.
Bedeutet, jedes Mal, wenn jemand ein Unity-Spiel auf seinem PC installiert, wird dem Unity-Server eine Nachricht geschickt und der Hersteller dürfte dafür blechen.
Wie Unity diese Zahlen genau tracken wollte, kann keiner sagen.
Und dazu gab es noch die etlichen anderen Probleme, die wir bereits in einem anderen Video durchgekaut haben.
Der Frust war und ist groß.
Viele bekannte Spielehersteller haben angekündigt, in Zukunft eine alternative Engine zu nutzen.
Und niemand, wirklich niemand, fand gut, was Unity da versuchte.
Unity war zudem immer sehr gut darin zu sagen, dass die Entwickler einfach nicht genau verstehen, was Unity vorhat und deswegen so sauer sind.
Sprich, wenn man deren Pläne verstehen würde, wären alle happy.
Das war das Einzige, was sie wirklich dazu angemerkt haben.
Sie haben im Endeffekt gesagt, ist doch gar nicht so schlimm.
Das Github-Projekt gelöscht haben, ist wohl einfach nebensächlich.
Das Github-Projekt existierte, um Änderungen an den Terms of Service zu verfolgen, damit man, wie in der aktuellen Situation, sehen könnte, dass hier etwas...
Dass man sich einen Diff angucken konnte, was hat sich denn geändert?
Heimlich geändert wurde.
Es wurde ins Leben gerufen, um Vertrauen aufzubauen.
Anscheinend ist dies kein großes Ziel mehr von der Firma.
Unities Entschuldigung ist also da.
Und direkt fällt einem auf, dass nicht John Riccitello, einer der meistgehassten Menschen...
Der war übrigens bei EA früher.
...das Statement schrieb.
Von ihm wurde von der gesamten Community gefordert, sein Amt abzulegen.
Da er, nachdem er EA zerstörte und abhaute, bei Unity anfing und man schon damals meinte, dass es für alle echt unangenehm ausgehen wird.
Nein, stattdessen schickt man Mark Whitten vor, ein in der Community bekanntes Gesicht, das gewählt wurde, da er sehr positiv bisher aufgenommen wurde über die Jahre.
Dies ist nichts gegen Mark, aber es ist ein richtig fader Beigeschmack, wenn der CEO sich weiterhin versteckt, der noch kurz zuvor...
Ja, das stimmt.
...dass dieser Backlash absolut nicht zu vermeiden war, egal was man gemacht hätte.
Ja, Moment. Hätten sie das nicht gemacht, dann hätte es auch keinen Backlash gegeben.
Für einen brillanten Vollidiot.
Aber gut, gehen wir fix die Änderungen durch.
Das ist Five-Head-Management-Logik.
Wer so nutzt, muss erst ab 200.000 Dollar auf die Pro-Lizenz umsteigen, als zuvor 100.000 Dollar.
Ebenso wird der Made-with-Unity-Splash-Screen entfernt.
Das Limit für die Installationsgebühr, die jetzt...
Äh, 7LQRS, danke für die Zeit.
...jetzt eine Engagementgebühr ist, beträgt nun 1.000.000 Dollar.
Danach gibt es die Wahl zwischen 2,5% des Umsatzes abgeben oder die Engagementgebühr zahlen, je nachdem, was günstiger ist.
Was diese Engagementgebühr ist, weiß keiner. Garantiert genau dasselbe wie früher, nur jetzt mit coolen neuen Namen.
Diese Zahlen, also Umsatz und Engagement, werden jedoch nun vom Hersteller des Spiels selbst übertragen und nicht mehr automatisch getrackt.
Weiterhin ist es also unklar, warum es dann nicht einfach nur eine Umsatzgebühr gibt.
Immerhin wäre das das Modell, das so ziemlich alle nutzen und halt auch am besten funktioniert.
Mark Whitten sagte in einem Interview, dass das Ziel war, die großen Firmen mehr zur Kasse zu bitten und die kleinen zu entlasten.
Wie aber jede Indie-Firma mit wenig Ausrechnung bemerkte, ist das kompletter Bullshit.
Immerhin sagen sie jetzt, dass man unter den Terms of Service der gewählten Unity-Version unterliegt.
Also so wie es ursprünglich in den Terms of Service auch stand.
Ja, okay, doch nicht mehr retroaktiv. Da ist ihnen wahrscheinlich aufgefallen, es wird schwierig sein durchzusetzen, rückwirkend alle Unity-Versionen.
Daher wird nichts mehr rückwirkend in Kraft gesetzt. Wie viele es bereits vorhergesagt haben, ist dies möglicherweise Taktik gewesen.
Erstmal richtig furchtbare neue Gebühren ankündigen, um dann zurückzurudern, damit die neuen Gebühren nicht so schlimm wirken.
Stimmt. Ja, das ist ja auch eine beliebte, sagen wir ein bisschen umgedreht, beliebte Free-to-Play-Taktik.
Wir bieten im Shop super tolle Sachen an, aber es gibt Kombi-Pakete, sodass einem die Kombi-Pakete besonders billig erscheinen.
Also vielleicht ist das ja auch so eine Taktik, so nach dem Motto, dass alle schreien und dann behält man eigentlich das, was man eh haben wollte, bei.
Und alle sagen, ja okay, ist ja gar nicht mehr so schlimm wie die erste Ankündigung, aber es ist immer noch beschissen.
Auch wenn ich mir sicher bin, dass alle diese Gebühren gut angenommen hätten, wären sie damit zuerst gekommen.
Unreal nimmt 5% des Umsatzes, 2,5% ist noch weit unter Unreal. Niemand hätte damit Probleme gehabt.
Und Knarr hat alles einen Haken. Du willst keinen Splash Queen haben? Dann musst du Unity 2024 nutzen und den neuen Terms of Service zustimmen.
Sprich, es wirkt eher wie ein Lockmittel, als wirklich eine Entschuldigung.
Achja, aber was hat eigentlich Unity dazu zu sagen, dass sie die Terms of Service geändert haben und das GitHub-Projekt löschten?
Unity ist enttäuscht, wie alle das harsch kritisiert haben, weil sie das Projekt nur gelöscht hatten, da es zu wenig Views bekam.
Na klar!
Wir haben es vor dem Preiswechsel entfernt, weil es zu wenig Views bekam.
Nämlich, ich hätte mir das niemals ausdenken können.
Was genau erwartet Unity? Dass wir alle vorm Schlafen gehen nochmal die Terms of Service-Grab durchlesen und sie fleißig Views sammeln?
Ist Unity jetzt ein Influencer, der darauf pocht, das GitHub-Projekt zu liken und den Accounts zu folgen?
Selbst wenn es nur 5 Views pro Jahr wären, sie existieren als Absicherung.
Damit, wenn etwas passiert, wie genau das, was jetzt passierte, man ohne Probleme kontrollieren kann, was geändert wurde.
Inklusive History.
Es wurde ja gelöscht, lange bevor die Preisänderungen kamen. Also ist es voll gemein, das gegen die Firma zu halten.
Ja, weil die gierigen CEOs nicht schon seit Langem diesen Müll geplant haben.
Zudem wurde das GitHub-Projekt vor ein paar Monaten gelöscht, nicht Jahren.
Aber wie halt schon die ganze Zeit über, gibt Unity den Usern damit die Schuld.
Es ist kein Einsehen, es ist kein Verstehen, es ist ein, es tut uns leid, dass ihr uns falsch verstanden habt, es voll gemein von euch so zu reagieren.
Und das Ganze hier könnte wieder passieren, denn Unity gibt eben keine Absicherungen für die Zukunft.
Ein Unity-Mitarbeiter hat extra einen ihrer Anwälte gefragt, wie es genau aussieht.
Und ja, sie können die Gebühren jederzeit ändern, auch rückwirkend, und alle können einen Scheiß dagegen tun.
Too bad, war Luigi-Time.
Der Anwalt von Unity sagt, ihr habt das zu akzeptieren, egal was wir machen, aber immerhin sagen wir ja 3 Monate vor Bescheid.
Ist diesen sehr, sehr intelligenten Menschen bewusst, dass Spiele nicht Wochen oder Monate, sondern meist Jahre in Entwicklung sind?
Das ist also ziemlich das Schlimmste, was sie hätten sagen können.
Nebenbei werden auch andere tolle Dinge umgesetzt.
Wusstet ihr zum Beispiel, dass Unity bald eine Always-Online-Software sein wird?
Wenn ihr ab November länger als 13 Tage offline seid, dürft ihr Unity nicht mehr nutzen.
What? Für eine Spieleentwicklung sollte es doch vollkommen egal sein?
Also ich meine, die meisten Leute sind eh online, weil sie Zeug nachgucken müssen und brauchen...
Hä? Was hat denn das eine mit dem anderen? Ich erkenne den Zusammenhang nicht.
Und müsst wieder online gehen.
Cool. Kann euch sagen, dass sowas nicht eingebaut wird, weil man seinen Kunden vertraut.
Was ironisch ist, wo Unity doch jetzt so stark darum kämpft, Vertrauen von unserer Seite wieder aufzubauen.
Jeder, der Unity weiterhin verwendet, muss im Klaren sein, dass weitere Änderungen jederzeit kommen können.
Während die Firma immer mehr und mehr Leute entlässt, die dazu da waren, die Engine endlich auf ein modernes...
Wann bist du immer live? Es gibt keine spezielle Zeit. Meistens abends halt, so wie jetzt in dem Dreh.
...einen Standard zu bringen, kauft sich stattdessen weiterhin komplett unsinnige Firmen, die nur dazu dienen, Aktionäre glücklich zu halten.
Der Kauf von Wetter ist keine Sache...
Was macht eigentlich die Unity-Kurs...
Oh. Ja, das war schon...
Also ich würde sagen, hier so ungefähr war das Announcement, hä?
Hier war das Announcement ungefähr?
Hier so. Hui!
Bisschen runter.
...die die Engine vorwärts bringt. Es ist die Antwort für die Aktionäre, was Unity tut, um gegen Unreal anzukämpfen,
da Unreal in der Film- und Werbebranche angekommen ist.
Was hirnrissig ist, Unreal ist als Engine dort angekommen.
Wetter hat nichts mit der Unity-Engine zu tun und wird es auch niemals.
Genauso wie Unity sich sehr hart für KI einsetzt, die immerhin teilweise etwas mit Unity-Editor zu tun hat.
Es wird aber garantiert nichts, was wirklich hilfreich sein wird.
Stattdessen ist es aber ein geiles Buzzword für die Aktionäre.
Unity mit KI-Unterstützung. Unser Wert wird steigen. Investiert in Unity.
Jeder Kauf, jede Fusionierung, jede Ankündigung der letzten 5 oder mehr Jahre sind niemals Sachen gewesen,
die Unity als Grafik- oder Videospiel-Engine weitergebracht haben.
Seit 3 Jahren ist Unity an der Börse und es ging seitdem rapide bergab.
Anders sieht es bei Epic Games aus, die Macher der Unreal-Engine.
Und Fortnite.
Epic ist nicht an der Börse. Epic wird weiterhin vom Gründer Tim Sweeney geführt.
Tim Sweeney besitzt auch weiterhin 150% der Firma.
Epic hat keine vage geschriebenen Terms of Service für die Unreal-Engine.
Und Epics Motto ist, wir sind erfolgreich, wenn ihr erfol-
Service für die Unreal-Engine.
Ist das aus Viva Pinata das Ding da hinten? Aus übelst lost, vergessenes Game, oder?
Und Epics Motto ist, wir sind erfolgreich, wenn ihr erfolgreich seid.
Eine der wohl besten Einstellungen, die man als Ersteller einer Videospiel-Engine haben kann.
Epic hat zudem Fortnite und den Epic Store.
Oder ist das das Fortnite-Lama?
Bei Dingen, wodurch sie niemals Probleme haben werden. Selbst wenn keiner mehr ihre Engine nutzen sollte.
Daher ist es nicht nötig, den Entwicklern mehr abzuknöpfen.
Im Gegenteil, in der Vergangenheit zeigten sie eher, dass sie den Entwicklern Geld zurückgeben.
Und dennoch sollte man vorsichtig sein und sich von nun an nicht mehr komplett auf Ein-Autoren-Systemen spezialisieren.
Auch Epic kann zum Beispiel nach einem Führungswechsel umschlagen und eine Situation erzeugen,
Game Maker? Ist das nicht das, wo die ganzen Weep-Graphic-Novel-Games drinne, oder wie man das nennt, Games drinne gemacht sind?
Situation erzeugen, wie es die nur mit Unity gibt.
Nur Open-Source-Engines wie Godot können davor schützen.
Nur muss man dann als großen Entwickler wieder speziell Engine-Entwickler einstellen.
Da niemand in der Schuld ist, die Probleme, die man gerade hat, direkt anzupacken, weil es halt Open-Source ist.
Godot könnte aber schon sehr bald einen Blender machen und von heute auf morgen einen festen Platz im professionellen Bereich haben.
Ich empfehle aktuell daher jeder Firma, diese Engine nicht aus dem Auge zu verlieren und selbst damit zu experimentieren.
Wenn dieser Umschlag kommt und Godot wie damals mit Blender 3.0 plötzlich auch für große Firmen eine valide Option wird,
wäre es klug, einer der ersten zu sein, die mit der Engine arbeiten, um nicht zurückgelassen zu werden.
So oder so bleibe ich dabei. Weiterhin auf Unity zu setzen, sehe ich als falsch an.
Und sobald man sein aktuelles Projekt fertig hat, sollte man sich Alternativen zumindest anschauen.
Wo ist Source Engine? Ich glaube nicht, dass die Source Engine aktuell zumindest so zum Lizenzieren zur Zeit irgendwie großartig noch relevant ist.
Ich glaube das letzte, ich meine Apex, ist Apex, beziehungsweise Titanfall wahrscheinlich so eines der letzten Games?
Schauen, denn das kann einfach nicht schaden. Es hat sich bei Unity intern nichts getan.
Dieselben Leute, die diesen ganzen Bullshit zu verantworten haben, sind weiterhin an der Spitze der Firma
und bekommen ihren jährlichen fetten Bonus zu ihrem abmenschlich hohen Grundgehalt.
Und laut ihnen wäre es ja unmöglich gewesen, dass es anders abgelaufen wäre, zumal es ja alle nur falsch verstanden haben.
Unity ist nur eine Firma an der Börse, wodurch die Kunden zweitrangig werden und die Aktionäre das Wichtigste sind.
Ihr könnt Gift darauf nehmen, dass wenn die Aktien nicht eingeknickt wären nach der Ankündigung, man auch nichts unternommen hätte.
Ich sehe es als fatal an, nun weiterzumachen, als wäre nie was passiert, auch wenn es natürlich viel bequemer ist.
Ich würde auch gerne alles ignorieren und Unity für immer weiter nutzen, als wäre nie was gewesen.
Das wäre viel einfacher. Aber es sich jetzt einfach zu machen, könnte in Zukunft fatale Folgen haben.
Ja. Ja. Ups. Leuchtet ein.
Glücklicherweise ist das mal so ein Technik-Thema, was mich null betrifft, weil Game-Entwicklung ist einfach nichts, was mich großartig interessiert.
Da muss ich aber glücklicherweise keine großen Gedanken drum machen.
Amazon-Engine, du meinst Lamp, Lamp, Lampia, Lampayat oder wie das Ding hieß.
Dieser Cry-Engine-Verschnitt, das juckt niemand. Nicht mal Amazon selbst will das benutzen.
Als Gamer betrifft es mich, aber ich entwickle ja keine Games.
Es betrifft mich indirekt als Gamer, aber ich muss mich nicht damit beschäftigen, wie ich jetzt irgendwelche Software-Projekte umgesetzt kriege.
Traum, danke für den Sub. Visual Novel, genau das meine ich.
Das ist doch immer in Game Maker gebaut, diese ganzen Weep-Games.
Wobei ich dafür nichts sage, ich bin mittlerweile ja selbst halber Weep.
Ich habe in letzter Zeit viel zu viele Animes geguckt, was jetzt für meine Verhältnisse viel, drei Stück oder so.
Eieiei, was haben wir denn sonst noch? Abenteuer Haus-Renovierung.
Ja, jedes Mal, wenn ich Windows benutzen muss.
Die Cloud ist Googles letzter Hoffnung.
Wait a minute, was? Das ist doch Debate, der Titel, oder?
Einfach erklärt.
Der meint das ernst? Okay, dann.
Aber 16 Minuten, okay, lass mal reinhören.
Also, das stimmt wohl.
Google ist mein Haupt-Haus-Renovierung.
Also, das stimmt wohl. Google ist Meister im Einstellen ihrer Produkte.
Dazu fällt mir immer nur ein.
Moment, Moment, ich muss es gerade mal raussuchen.
Da muss ich immer an Stadia denken.
Es gibt ja eine schöne Seite für sowas.
Nennt sich, ähm, Moment.
Nennt sich Killed by Google.
Und da findet man einen Friedhof mit Google-Produkten, die eingestellt wurden.
Das letzte, was es erwischt hat, ist wohl Google Jamboard.
Okay, das habe ich noch nie gehört.
Kennt irgendjemand von euch Jamboard?
Google Podcasts?
Google Domains? Ja, das ist es.
Google Domains? Ja, das wusste ich gar nicht mal, dass es das gab.
Ist schon beeindruckend, was Google da am Start hat.
An Einstellungshistory.
Und Bart ist noch nicht eingestellt.
Ach so, dass das keiner groß benutzen möchte, ja, okay.
Also, gibt es wirklich Leute, die zu Edge wechseln?
Wie keiner haben wollte, ja.
Ich glaube, Shorts ist sogar so semi-erfolgreich, ganz okay.
Es sieht so aus, als hätte Google sich eine Seite aus dem Handbuch von Microsoft kopiert.
Im Gegensatz zu Microsoft, das Anfang der 2010er-Jahre in die Cloud-Szene eingestiegen ist,
kam Google erst in den späten 2010er-Jahren dazu,
was es für das Unternehmen außerordentlich schwierig machte, sich durchzusetzen.
Dafür haben die wirklich ein paar ganz coole Sachen.
Ich bin der Meinung, von den ganzen Managed Kubernetes-Plattformen,
dass Google da lange Zeit schon ein bisschen voraus war und auch immer noch ist.
Es gibt zwar nun, glaube ich, sogar auch bei AWS so Fully-Managed-Cluster,
wobei ich mir gar nicht sicher bin, aber ich glaube, AWS hat mittlerweile auch sowas.
Ein bisschen aufgeholt.
Aber ich glaube, sowas wie Autopilot haben die anderen beiden immer noch nicht.
Also, Google Cloud, technisch muss ich sagen, ich mache ja auf der Arbeit auch viel damit,
ich finde das echt nicht schlecht.
Jahren von Dollar bei dem Versuch, den Cloud-Markt zu erobern,
bis es Anfang dieses Jahres zum ersten Mal einen Gewinn verbuchen konnte,
und wenn man bedenkt, dass 50% aller offenen Stellen bei Google im Cloud-Bereich ausgeschrieben werden,
kann man mit Sicherheit sagen, dass Google das Cloud-Geschäft für Unternehmen weiter ausbauen will.
Werfen wir also gemeinsam einen Blick auf Googles monumentalen Wandel
von einem allgegenwärtigen Privatkundenunternehmen zu einem Riesen im Unternehmensbereich.
Ein Blick zurück zeigt, dass die Geschichte von Google Cloud im März 2006
mit dem Start von AWS oder Amazon Web Services beginnt.
Ich persönlich bevorzuge immer noch AWS,
einfach weil ich W so unglaublich bescheuert finde von der Aussprache her.
Goldstandard in Sachen Cloud und praktisch jedes namhafte Unternehmen,
das ihr euch vorstellen könnt, begann AWS zu nutzen.
Zu den bekanntesten Kunden gehört Airbnb, McDonalds, Twitch, Twitter, Epic Games
oder auch Netflix und Disney.
Einige Analysten schätzen sogar, dass AWS eine Billion Dollar
der Marktkapitalisierung von Amazon ausmacht.
Mit anderen Worten, das riesige Einzelhandelsgeschäft, das jeder kennt,
ist nur ein paar hundert Milliarden oder nur ein Bruchteil der gesamten Bewertung von Amazon wert.
Aber als Amazon AWS auf den Markt brachte,
wollte das Unternehmen keineswegs das nächste große Ding schaffen.
Tatsächlich war der Start von AWS eher ein verzweifelter als ein kalkulierter Schritt.
Amazons Einzelhandelsgeschäft warf einfach keinen Gewinn ab
und da die Finanzierung aufgrund des Dotcom-Crashs versiegte,
brauchte das Unternehmen eine andere Einnahme.
Ich habe keine Ahnung von der AWS-History, aber gut, jetzt kriegen wir das ein bisschen erzählt.
Die Lösung bestand darin, ihre überzähligen Server und Datenbanken zu vermieten,
was sich zu einem Billionen-Dollar-Geschäft entwickelte.
Google beobachtete all dies in Echtzeit und war natürlich der Meinung,
dass sie es besser machen konnten.
Im April 2008 betrat Google die Cloud-Bühne mit der Einführung von App Engine.
Stimmt, ich erinnere mich. Ich erinnere mich.
Es sollte für Entwickler einfacher als je zuvor werden, Websites zu erstellen,
indem sie sich die Leistungsfähigkeit der Google-Infrastruktur zunutze machen können.
Google vereinfachtete die Prozesse zur Bereitstellung von Code
und Bewältigung von Traffic-Spitzen weitgehend.
Tatsächlich haben sie diese Probleme sogar komplett eliminiert,
da sich Google selbst um diese Dinge kümmern würde.
Aber sie wollten App Engine nicht nur so benutzerfreundlich wie möglich machen,
sondern auch so billig wie möglich.
Tatsächlich gab es in der ursprünglichen Version nicht einmal eine kostenpflichtige Option.
Jeder bekam ein großzügiges Gratiskontingent, mit dem er herumspielen und testen konnte.
Ja, das ist ja eine Taktik, was viele Anbieter gerne machen.
Wenn der Kram neu ist, wird es quasi halb verschenkt.
Aber das geht dann nicht für immer so.
Da es sich um ein Angebot von Google handelte,
zog es natürlich eine Menge Entwickler an. 20.000, um genau zu sein.
Ein Monat später öffneten sie den Dienst für alle Entwickler
und 10 Monate später fügten sie der App Engine kostenpflichtige Stufen hinzu.
Aber irgendetwas stimmte nicht.
App Engine war bei weitem am einfachsten zu bedienen und am günstigsten,
vor allem von den Angeboten der großen Technologieunternehmen.
Aber aus irgendeinem Grund blieben die Entwickler nicht dabei.
Die haben wahrscheinlich gedacht, fuck, das ist Google,
das wird wahrscheinlich in einem halben Jahr eingestellt.
Äußerst verwirrend.
Google hatte dieselbe Strategie wie immer angewandt,
meist mit großem Erfolg.
Einen besseren Service zu einem günstigeren Preis
oder kostenlos anzubieten war das Brot- und Buttergeschäft von Google.
Warum also um alles in der Welt
meldeten sich die Entwickler nicht massenhaft an?
Nun, die Realität war,
dass Google die Entwicklergemeinschaft völlig falsch verstanden hatte.
Was ziemlich ironisch ist, wenn man bedenkt,
dass Google selbst aus einem Haufen Entwickler besteht.
Das Problem war, dass Google,
um den Dienst so benutzerfreundlich wie möglich zu gestalten,
eine Menge an Anpassungsmöglichkeiten opfern musste.
Um den Aspekt der Benutzerfreundlichkeit zu erfüllen,
musste Google die unendliche Entwicklerlandschaft
in ein paar knappe Kästchen schrumpfen lassen.
Denn ehrlich gesagt konnten sie nur eine begrenzte Zeit
Hat jemand von euch mal App Engine benutzt?
Mir sagt der Name was, aber hab ich nie.
Übrigens, diese Türen sind nice.
Hatten wir auch im RZ.
Und im D6 gibt's auch so Türen, da wirst du gewogen, wenn du reingehst.
Weiß nicht, ob das noch so ist.
Ich war jetzt schon ein paar Jahre nicht mehr da.
In Kombination mit den CPU-Beschränkungen,
Skalierungsproblemen und langsamen Antwortzeiten war
Was, Chat? Ich finde nur echt, dass der komisch spricht.
Der spricht so, weil er das von einem Skript abliest.
Aber das ist doch gut geschrieben, also find ich jetzt nicht schlimm.
Die Entwickler schon vor dem Start von App Engine enttäuscht.
Google hatte allerdings keine Angst davor zu scheitern
und es erneut zu versuchen.
Und so war es nur eine Frage der Zeit,
bis sie ein neues Angebot herausbrachten.
Ein Jahr nach dem Start von App Engine
fügte Google Java-Unterstützung hinzu, aber das änderte nicht viel.
Jabber?
Jabber oder Java?
Das hab ich jetzt nicht verstanden.
Ein Jahr nach dem Start von App Engine
fügte Google Java-Unterstützung hinzu, aber das änderte nicht viel.
Ja-wa. Ja-wa. Ja-wa.
Ich hab Jabber verstanden,
aber ich hab gesagt, was ist so ein Tollmanni mit Jabber?
...Stützung hinzu, aber das änderte nicht viel.
Dieser Entwickler sagte,
es gibt ein paar grundlegende Probleme, die gelöst werden...
Nein, nein, es ist definitiv Java. Guck mal.
Ja.
MonkaJava.
...grundlegende Probleme, die gelöst werden müssen,
bevor Google App Engine als Plattform für Web-Anwendungen
ernst genommen werden kann.
Und nein, die Java-Unterstützung gehört definitiv nicht dazu.
Also gut.
Wenn es nicht Java ist, was sie wollen,
dann ist es vielleicht Cloud-Speicher?
Nein.
BigQuery und Prediction APIs?
BigQuery ist, glaube ich, die...
Ist das nicht die NoSQL-Geschichte von Google?
SQL? Nein.
Cloud SQL ist wirklich nicht schlecht.
Benutze ich recht oft.
Das ist echt super simpel, easy und tut...
24 mal 7 Telefonsupport?
Äh, wat?
PHP-Support? Nein.
Verschlüsselung? Fehlanzeige.
Die Erweiterung, die Google in den nächsten 5 Jahren
zu seinem Cloud-Angebot hinzufügte,
konnte die großen Jungs wirklich überzeugen.
Die Quintessenz war, dass der Consumer-Ansatz
bei Entwicklern und Unternehmenskunden nicht funktioniert hat.
Google versuchte, eine verwässerte Version anzubieten,
die billig und einfach zu bedienen war,
während die Entwickler eine vollständig anpassbare Option bevorzugten,
für die sie nur allzu gerne zahlten.
Ironischerweise war Amazons einfaches Angebot
viel attraktiver als Googles verwässertes Sortiment.
Das war sehr frustrierend.
Google versuchte buchstäblich,
ein Angebot für Entwickler zu schaffen,
das einfacher und bequemer war als alles andere auf dem Markt,
aber aus irgendeinem Grund bevorzugten die Entwickler
das weniger bequeme Angebot.
Frustriert wandte sich Google wieder...
Weiß ich nicht, ob das...
War das wirklich der Hintergrund?
Das klingt mir jetzt ein bisschen
sehr aus den Fingern gesaugt irgendwie.
Also ich hab von den Anfängen
weder von AWS noch von Google Cloud
jetzt irgendwie eine große Ahnung,
was da vergleichbar war
oder was da anders war.
Aber ich meine,
du wirst heute in der Google Cloud
mit Optionen und möglichen Services erschlagen.
Das wirst du bei jedem Cloud-Anbieter.
Du kannst eigentlich so gut wie alles
auch anpassen.
Also du kannst beispielsweise,
wenn du eine VM erstellst,
du brauchst keine vorgefertigte VM,
kannst auch custom alles auswählen,
wenn du willst.
Das heißt, du kannst auch
System-Images, Netzwerkoptionen und so.
Das steht jetzt ehrlich gesagt
Azure auch nicht so viel nach.
Mit AWS kenne ich mich am wenigsten aus.
AWS konnte man sehr viel mehr machen.
Keine Ahnung, wie gesagt,
ich habe von AWS keinen großen Plan.
Dem zu, was es am besten konnte,
den Verbrauchermarkt.
Und so kam es,
dass Google Drive am 24. April 2012
auf den Markt kam.
In klassischer Google-Manier
starteten sie mit 15 GB
auf den Markt.
Innerhalb von drei Jahren
wuchs die Zahl der zahlenden Nutzer
auf eine Million.
Im Jahr 2017 wurde der Meilenstein erreicht,
mehr als zwei Billionen Dateien zu speichern.
Und im Jahr 2018
waren es eine Milliarde aktive Nutzer.
Nach allem, was man hört,
war Google Drive ein großer Erfolg.
Aber Google konnte sich des Eindrucks
nicht erwehren,
dass man den größeren Kuchen verpasst hatte.
Den Unternehmensmarkt.
Sicherlich war es großartig,
aber mit einem Cloud-Betrieb wie AWS
könnten sie buchstäblich
Billionen von Nutzer
über Hunderte
von allgegenwärtigen Plattformen erreichen.
Dieses Gefühl wurde durch
den überraschenden Erfolg von Microsoft Azure,
das Jahre nach App Engine
auf den Markt kam,
nur noch verstärkt.
Außerdem hat Microsoft mit Azure
nicht einmal versucht,
etwas Revolutionäres zu machen wie Google.
Ihr gesamtes Angebot war im Grunde
nur AWS für weniger Geld.
Sie versuchten im Jahr 2014,
dass sie sich den Weg an die Spitze
nicht erkämpfen,
sondern kaufen würden.
Dieser Plan hatte zwei Seiten.
Auf der einen Seite
würden sie kleinere Cloud-Anbieter
und deren Nutzer wie Firebase aufkaufen
und auf der anderen Seite
würden sie ihre Cloud-Angebote
mit einer lächerlichen Summe
subventionieren.
Tatsächlich würden sie die Preise
für alle Cloud-Angebote
zwischen 30% und 85% senken.
Ja, das sollen sie mal machen.
Heute merke ich davon nichts mehr.
Also gerade VMs und sowas
sind übertrieben teuer bei Google.
Nicht wirklich viel teurer
oder ähnlich teuer bei den anderen Anbietern,
großen Cloud-Anbietern.
Auch bei AWS weiß ich nicht,
aber ähnlich teuer.
Nur für VMs lohnt sich das nach wie vor nicht.
Sicherlich war dieses Angebot
zu gut, um es abzulehnen,
bis die Kunden es ablehnten.
Die harte Realität war,
dass kein Unternehmen
einen Grund zu wechseln hatte,
wenn es bereits 2 großartige Angebote gab.
AWS und Azure.
Eines, das sich auf die Leistung konzentrierte
und eines, das sich auf den Preis konzentrierte.
Google passte einfach nicht in diese Szene
und nachdem sie die Preise weitgehend gesenkt hatten,
verbrannten sie lächerliche Mengen an Geld.
In der schlimmsten Zeit verloren sie
allein im Cloud-Bereich
5,5 Milliarden Dollar pro Jahr.
Sundar versuchte verzweifelt
die Investoren davon zu überzeugen,
dass Google Cloud nach dem Wachstum
keine Zahlen beurteilt werden sollte.
Aber die Investoren waren nicht überzeugt,
denn das Wachstum war im Vergleich
zu den echten Gewinnern
nicht einmal besonders bemerkenswert.
Zu allem Überfluss war dies die Zeit,
in der auch alle neuen Google-Angebote
für Verbraucher zu floppen begannen.
Google brauchte eine Veränderung.
Und zwar schnell.
Und die war Thomas Kurien.
Um ehrlich zu sein,
hatte Google mit Thomas Kurien
den Kerl habe ich legit noch nie gesehen.
Außer ordentliches Glück.
Wenn ihr Thomas Kurien nicht kennt,
ist das verständlich,
denn er hat die meiste Zeit seiner Karriere
im Hintergrund verbracht.
Was aber nicht heißen soll,
dass seine Beiträge nicht außergewöhnlich waren.
Nachdem er zu Beginn seiner Karriere
ein paar Jahre als Berater gearbeitet hatte,
kam Thomas 1996 zu Oracle.
In den folgenden 12 Jahren
arbeitete er sich
bis zum Präsidenten von Oracle hoch
und war nur noch
dem Gründer und CEO von Oracle
Larry Ellison unterstellt.
Thomas war der Traumkandidat für Google,
denn er hatte buchstäblich
seine gesamte Karriere damit verbracht,
dass die Oracle Cloud
das größte Enterprise-Tech-Unternehmen
der Welt aufzubauen.
Oracle.
Er war für 35.000 Entwickler
und Budgets
in Höhe von 10 Milliarden Dollar verantwortlich
und war de facto
der CEO von Oracle,
da Larry Ellison im Ruhestand war.
Doch obwohl Thomas
der perfekte Kandidat
war,
hatte Google keine Chance ihn zu bekommen.
Warum sollte er das erfolgreichste
Technologieunternehmen der Welt,
in dem er bereits der wichtigste Mann war,
verlassen,
um das angeschlagene Unternehmen
Google Cloud zu leiten?
Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Wenn ihr denkt,
dass Google ihn mit Geld bestechen könnte,
ist das auch falsch,
denn er braucht kein Geld.
Wir reden immer davon,
dass Google ein sehr gut zahlender
Unternehmen ist,
das alles schon erlebt hat.
Tatsächlich war Thomas 2010
der fünftbestbezahlte
Tech-Manager der Welt,
bevor Sundar überhaupt gab
und im Jahr 2018 verdiente Thomas
knapp 100 Millionen Dollar.
Zu diesem Zeitpunkt
stand Thomas eigentlich der Werdegang
bevor CSuite-Manager
oder sogar CEO zu werden.
Möglicherweise noch mehr zu verdienen
als Sundar Pichai,
weitere 10 Jahre
sind noch zu kommen
und das ist der Grund,
warum wir überhaupt über Thomas sprechen.
Etwa zur gleichen Zeit,
als Google dringend Hilfe brauchte,
gerieten Thomas und Larry
in einen heftigen Streit
über die Zukunft von Oracle Cloud.
Thomas war der Meinung,
dass Oracle mehr seiner Software
auf AWS und Azure betreiben sollte,
um mehr Kunden zu erreichen,
während Larry der Meinung war,
dass Oracle Software
in seiner eigenen Cloud betreiben sollte,
diese Meinungsverschiedenheit
nahm schnell überhand
und am 28. September 2018
verkündete Thomas,
dass er bei Oracle kündigen
und sich aktiv nach neuen Möglichkeiten
umsehen würde.
Für Google war das ein wahrer Segen.
In einer Zeit,
in der das Unternehmen
mehr Hilfe brauchte als je zuvor,
suchte einer der qualifiziertesten
Cloud-Manager der Welt
nach einem neuen Job.
Wahrscheinlich waren die einzigen
und hatte also das Glück,
aus dem Nichts
die drittbeste Wahl
auf der ganzen Welt zu treffen.
Ja, ich glaube nicht,
dass es euch überrascht,
dass Thomas Anfang 2018
als CEO von Google Cloud
eingestellt wurde.
Aber der Weg dorthin
war alles andere als einfach,
denn Thomas übernahm
Buchstaben und
Buchstäblich eine
Geldverbrennungsmaschine.
Thomas sagt,
dass als er anfing,
das Hauptproblem bei Google Cloud
nicht schwer zu erkennen war.
Das Problem war,
dass Google sich darauf konzentrierte,
ausgefeilte Technologien zu entwickeln,
obwohl es eigentlich darum ging,
Lösungen zu entwickeln.
Die erste Aufgabe
bestand also darin,
die Denkweise von
verschiedenen Lösungsunternehmen
zu ändern.
Anstatt also einen Haufen
Entwickler einzustellen,
stellte Thomas eine Reihe
von Vertriebsingenieuren
und Lösungsarchitekten ein.
Diese kümmern sich
um bestehende und neue Kunden
und gehen auf all ihre Fragen
und Bedenken ein,
damit Google das erreichen kann,
was sie sich erhoffen.
Um diesen Mentalitätswandel
zu festigen,
kostete Google 1,4 Milliarden Dollar.
All diese internen Veränderungen
waren für die Produktentwicklung
und den Vertrieb sehr hilfreich,
aber Thomas größter Schachzug
war wahrscheinlich ein neues
Alleinstellungsmerkmal zu finden.
Wie ich bereits erwähnt habe,
sticht AWS wegen seiner Leistung,
Azure wegen seines Preises
und Google wegen seiner
Benutzerfreundlichkeit heraus.
Das Unternehmen stellt jedoch fest,
dass Entwickler sich nicht so sehr
für die Benutzerfreundlichkeit
kümmern.
Lösungsarchitekten,
das ist eindeutig ein
Solution-Architekt oder sowas.
Ja, das sagt man eigentlich,
ich glaube, das sagt man im Deutsch
wirklich nicht so.
Merkmal, und da stieß Thomas
auf den Open-Source-Cloud-Markt.
Open-Source-Plattformen
wie MongoDB und Elasticsearch
hatten nicht nur Schwierigkeiten
mit AWS zu konkurrieren,
Elasticsearch,
die sind da richtig mit AWS
und Azure angegriffen.
Als Thomas dies sah, wusste er genau,
was ihr Alleinstellungsmerkmal
sein würde.
Sie würden der Champion für
Open-Source-Cloud-Lösungen sein
und so ging er eine Partnerschaft
mit sieben der beliebtesten
Open-Source-Lösungen ein.
Damit konnten die Entwickler
von der enormen Leistungsfähigkeit
der Google-Infrastruktur profitieren
und gleichzeitig die wahnsinnigen
Freiheiten und Anpassungen
nutzen, die diese
Open-Source-Plattformen bieten.
Und das war's.
Das war der Wendepunkt,
der schließlich große Kunden
wie Coinbase, Deutsche Bank,
Ford, General Mills und SpaceX
unlockte.
Tatsächlich entwickelt sich
Google Cloud jetzt sogar besser
als das Anzeigengeschäft,
das stagniert.
Auf Google Cloud entfällt
inzwischen auch ein Viertel
der gesamten Google-Belegschaft
im Wachstum sprechen.
Das Unternehmen hat viel Platz
dafür, denn es kontrolliert
immer noch nur etwa 10% des Marktes.
All das bringt uns zurück
zu Googles ursprünglichen Problem,
nämlich dass keines seiner
jüngsten Produkte bei den
Verbrauchern ankommt und die
bestehenden Produkte langsam an
Dampf verlieren.
Das ist für jedes Unternehmen
kein gutes Zeichen,
aber zum Glück für Google
scheint es so, als hätten sie
eine Chance.
Während Googles Zukunft
auf dem Verbrauchermarkt düster
aussieht, sieht die Zukunft
auf dem Unternehmensmarkt
besser denn je aus.
Und deshalb ist die Cloud
jetzt Googles wichtigstes Geschäft.
Danke fürs Zuschauen.
Schaut euch doch jetzt
eines unserer anderen Videos an
und wenn ihr mehr Fragen
einfacher erklärt haben wollt,
abonniert gerne den Kanal.
Und die Nokia-Übernahme,
bei Microsoft ist das ähnlich.
Die scheißen nicht umsonst so
auf viele Produkte,
die richtige Klassiker waren
so bei Microsoft immer.
Guckt euch an,
Office ist mittlerweile fast
ein reiner Cloud-Service geworden.
Bleibt noch Windows übrig.
Und wie viel Liebe Windows bekommt,
erkennt man ja ganz gut.
Gar keine.
Außer dass sie super emotionale
Presentations halten,
wo fast geheult wird.
Du hast zwar ein paar Überschneidungen,
aber GKE konfiguriert sich anders
als ein, wie heißt denn das?
Wie heißt denn das Gegenstück bei AWS?
Ich kenn mich mit AWS nicht aus.
Bei AKS ist es nicht,
das ist Azure EKS.
Stimmt, bei denen heißt ja alles
Elastic davor.
Was mich bei AWS
immer am meisten verwirrt,
wenn ich da mal was drüber lese
und höre, ist die Bezeichnung
für alles.
Klar, bei Google ist auch nicht
unbedingt klar, dass BigQuery
beispielsweise, ich glaube,
dass es die neue SQL-Datenbank ist.
Ein paar Sachen sind nicht so,
aber zum größten Teil klingt das
irgendwie passend.
Und bei Azure auch halbwegs.
Aber bei AWS hast du sowas wie
Route 53.
Das ist halt richtig geek-nice,
weil DNS-Port 53,
aber niemand checkts,
der es nicht weiß.
Okay.
Ja, aber es ist auf jeden Fall
ein Unterschied, ob du ein GKE
in Terraform anlegen möchtest
oder ein EKS.
AWS Lightsail,
ja, das ist genau das gleiche.
Gab es nicht noch irgendwie
AWS Snow Truck
oder irgendwie sowas?
Oder wie hieß das?
AWS Snow Patrol
oder irgendwie sowas,
wo du irgendwie deine Festplatten
reinladen konntest?
AWS Snow Mobile, ja.
Ja, für die Festplatten.
Der Festplatten-Truck.
Ja, das ist vielleicht
in dem spezifischen Kontext
ein bisschen blöd,
aber zumindest erkennst du sofort
anhand des Namens,
dass es sich irgendwas um
Message Queue, Event Bus,
irgendwas in der Richtung handelt.
Ja, Outpost.
Also bei AWS stehe ich immer
komplett auf dem Schlauch,
was es ist,
wie SARS quasi oder wie.
Also, keine Ahnung.
Das ist bei AWS.
Das verwirrt mich immer bei AWS.
Okay.
Ja, Leute, leider hat das
mit dem Mojo heute nicht funktioniert,
aber Ubuntu extra dafür näht.
Das sehe ich nicht ein.
Ich warte mal ab,
bis es den Krempel ordentlich zum
Installieren unter Anstehung gibt,
dann gucken wir uns das nochmal an.
Es ist jetzt 21.06,
ich würde sagen,
ich würde das Mojo angucken,
aber das hat nicht so richtig funktioniert.
Outpost.
Lass mich mal kurz angucken,
wie es morgen aussieht.
Ha, morgen ist auch
den ganzen Tag wieder Gemiete, ey.
Ohne Scheiß, was ist denn das wieder?
Okay, morgen, pass mal auf,
mein Meeting-Tag.
9 Uhr geht es los.
IT, Dingsbums,
Leitungskreis, Vorstellung,
irgendwas, Viertelstunde.
Easy.
Weekly Catch-Up Call.
Gruppenrunde.
11.30 bis 13.30,
Super-Top-Secret-Termin.
14.00 Uhr, Teamrunde.
Austausch- und Sync-Termin.
15.00 bis 16.00 Uhr.
Ja, da bin ich aber auf E weg.
Und dann, Keckel,
da gehe ich nicht hin.
Woho, jetzt wolltest du es wissen.
Lul.
16.00 Uhr bis 17.00 Uhr,
Jurfix Projektsteuerung.
Ganz bestimmt, ganz bestimmt.
Und jetzt pass mal auf,
es geht noch weiter.
17.00 bis 18.00 Uhr,
Status-Abnahme-Umgebung.
Die können mich mal gerne haben.
16.00 Uhr bin ich weg.
Ich glaube, es geht los, Alter.
Sind die von allen guten Geistern verlassen, oder was?
Kack-Bye.
Also 16.00 Uhr spätestens,
16.00 Uhr bin ich fort.
16.20 Uhr, 16.25 Uhr fährt der Zug.
Okay, ratet mal, was ich morgen arbeiten werde.
Also das geht los,
um 9.00 Uhr.
Nichts, richtig, nichts.
Ich habe, ohne Scheiß,
es ist von 9.00 Uhr bis 9.15 Uhr,
von 9.30 Uhr bis 9.45 Uhr,
von 11.30 Uhr bis 11.00 Uhr,
von 10.35 Uhr bis 11.25 Uhr,
es überschneidet sich sogar.
Von 11.30 Uhr bis 13.30 Uhr,
von 14.00 Uhr bis 15.25 Uhr,
von 15.00 Uhr bis 16.00 Uhr.
Okay, das überschneidet sich auch immer die ganze Zeit schon.
Okay, ich kriege morgen mal wieder
richtig einen heißen Stundenlohn für nichts.
Ich denke mir, soll mir recht sein?
Ist okay?
Die wollen das so, ist nicht mein Problem.
Achso, angeblich sollen bis Ende der Woche
noch ein paar Sachen aufgebaut sein,
aber das wird nichts.
Morgen ist Mittwoch.
Okay, morgen ist Mittwoch.
Morgen werde ich legit den ganzen Tag
nichts machen außer mieten.
Nicht möglich, da irgendwas zu machen.
Donnerstag.
Ah, muss ich Monitoring morgens angucken?
Bin ich für zuständig?
9.30 Uhr bis 9.45 Uhr,
Projekt Daily Scrum.
Team Daily.
Okay, dann habe ich mal eine Stunde bis 12.00 Uhr nichts.
Und dann gibt es
Coupanetes Schuhfix.
Okay, es wird immer mehr Geschuhe fixet.
Onboarding.
Okay, dann habe ich mal eine Stunde bis 12.00 Uhr nichts.
Und dann kommt Abteilungsversammlung.
Tja.
Uff, 10.00 bis 18.00 Uhr.
Ja, ist klar, Leute.
Ich glaube, das geht nur so lange,
weil es dann irgendwie umsonst noch was zu essen gibt.
Da bin ich auch,
sobald der offizielle Teil rum ist,
weg.
Und dann wollen sie nebenbei parallel 17.00 bis 18.00 Uhr mieten.
Alter, ich...
Was ist mit den Leuten los, Alter?
Wollen die nicht einfach mal privat auch was machen?
Wollen die irgendwie alle bis Mitternacht auf der Arbeit hocken oder wie?
Wer macht Mietings 17.00 bis 18.00 Uhr, Mann?
Ich verstehe es nicht.
Gehe ich nicht hin.
Also vielleicht, je nachdem,
wenn die Abteilungsversammlung ein bisschen länger geht,
fahre ich vielleicht einen Zug später.
Kommen bestimmt ein paar ganz interessante Sachen rum.
Aber das heißt, ich mache am Donnerstag
auch nicht wirklich was.
Außer vielleicht mal 1, 1,5, 2 Stunden maximal.
Nice.
Bleibt ja noch Freitag übrig.
Gucken wir mal, wie es Freitag aussieht.
Wie sage ich Nein zu sowas?
Entweder, entweder Nein sagen,
oder mach so wie ich.
Geh einfach hin
und chill dein Leben,
weil die wollen es so.
Und kassiere Geld dafür,
dass du halt nichts machst.
Dass du auf Verlangen nichts machst.
Kann ich ja nichts für.
Ich finde es auch kacke.
Ich würde auch lieber gerne Technik-Krams machen.
Aber wenn die von mir wollen,
dass ich quasi nichts arbeite,
also auf Verlangen nichts arbeite,
dann arbeite ich auch nichts.
Das ist okay.
Geld gibt es trotzdem.
So, mal gucken, ob ich Freitag,
oh ne, ne, ne, Leute.
Okay, Freitag, Freitag geht es weiter.
Okay, Daily Scrum fürs Projekt.
Die sagen da nichts.
Die wissen, dass ich 16 Uhr spätestens weg bin.
Nö.
Entweder sagst du die ab
oder nimmst das Meeting einfach erst gar nicht an.
Ne, also 17 Uhr gehe ich nicht hin.
Nach allen Meetings nach 16 Uhr gehe ich nicht hin.
Okay, es sei denn, es ist eine jährliche Abteilungsversammlung
oder so, kann man das mal machen.
Aber ansonsten ist nichts.
Ich meine, ich bin ganz normal 7 Uhr da
und meine Arbeitszeit ist irgendwann halt auch mal vorbei.
So gegen 15 Uhr, 30 Uhr, spätestens 16 Uhr.
So, mal gucken, ob ich Freitag Zeit habe, was zu machen.
Also, geht schon mal gut los
mit Projekt-Daily und Team-Daily.
Also von 9.30 Uhr bis 10.15 Uhr wird komplett gedailied.
Dann gibt es ...
Oh, da habe ich ja Bock drauf.
Dann geht es weiter.
10 Uhr bis 11 Uhr Erklärung Change-Prozess.
Oh, Keck-Business-Zeug.
Oh, jajaja.
Ja, das ist also nicht nur für mich,
weil ich neu bin, sondern das kriegen alle dort erklärt.
10 Uhr bis 11 Uhr Change-Prozess, neuer Change-Prozess.
Okay, dann haben wir von 11 bis 12 ...
Aha, geht weiter.
Onboarding-Support.
Was auch immer, keine Ahnung.
Aber von 11 bis 12.
Dann haben wir Ansible-Abstimmung.
Aha, 13 bis 14 Uhr.
Da wird Ansible-Hacker-Man gemacht.
Dann haben wir unseren Friday-Call für das Team.
14 bis 14.15 Uhr.
Und dann ist fertig.
Leute, ich kann am Freitag eineinhalb Stunden arbeiten.
Geil, oder?
Yeah!
Ich habe schon einen Blocker eingetragen.
Ich habe einen Blocker drin.
Ich habe aber jeden Tag einen Blocker drin.
15.30 Uhr bis 7 Uhr am nächsten Tag
habe ich immer einen Blocker drin,
dass mir keiner so späte Meetings reindrückt.
Machen sie trotzdem.
Aber da gehe ich halt einfach nicht hin.
Leute, ich kann eineinhalb Stunden arbeiten am Freitag.
Ist das nicht geil?
Also ich komme in drei Arbeitstagen ungefähr auf ...
Sehen wir mal großzügig vier Stunden Arbeitszeit,
wo ich wirklich was arbeiten kann.
Der Rest ist voll mit Gemiete.
Nice!
Excellent!
Oder was sagt ihr?
Wie sieht das bei euch so aus?
High Performer.
Der Zug ist bei mir abgefahren.
Wie sieht das bei euch so aus mit Meeting Pensum?
Leute, ich arbeite noch weniger.
Ich sehe es ja gerade.
Ich arbeite noch weniger.
Weil ich habe sowohl Donnerstag als auch Freitag
Monitoring Frühschicht Überwachungsdienst.
Also wir haben das so eingeteilt,
dass immer einer morgens, immer einer mittags
und immer einer abends zuständig ist
auf aktuelle Monitoring Probleme
und reinkommende Incident Tickets zu reagieren.
Das mache ich am Donnerstag und Freitag morgens.
Da mache ich noch weniger.
Gut, das zählt zur Arbeit dabei.
Sag mal, ich bleibe mal vier Stunden in drei Tagen.
Vier Stunden arbeiten in drei Tagen.
Der Rest ist Meeting
oder kurz ein paar Minuten zwischen Meetings
und ab und zu mal was futtern.
Was ist das?
Ja, das geht ja bei euch.
Also ihr habt es jetzt gesehen,
bei mir ist das fast jede Woche so.
Also ich habe bestimmt 50% der Zeit Gemiete.
Das kommt, denke ich, gut hin.
50% der Zeit.
Wird in den Meetings nicht deine Expertise gefordert?
Doch, ab und zu schon.
Aber meistens ist es eigentlich sehr gechillt.
Wenn es um irgendwelche Technik Themen geht,
gebe ich da mal meinen Senf dazu.
Nebenbei tippe ich vielleicht mal ein bisschen was.
GoPro habe ich bestellt.
Doch, wenn es um irgendwelche Infrastruktursachen geht,
gebe ich meinen Senf dazu.
Ansonsten lasse ich die machen.
Wenn es mir gar so sehr auf den Keks geht,
wenn man wieder in der Gruppenrunde im Kreis diskutiert wird,
sage ich auch mal was.
Aber ansonsten lasse ich die alle machen.
Ich meine, es gibt ja nichts,
worüber man sich beschweren könnte im Endeffekt.
Also aus Arbeitgebersicht.
Die wollen, dass ich da hingehe.
Ich gehe da hin und ich kriege Geld dafür.
Für alle Beteiligten, top.
Es ist im Prinzip bezahltes Däumchentränen.
Den größten Teil der Meetingzeiten.
Aber sie wollen es so.
Was soll ich machen?
Ich finde es auch nicht toll.
Aber ich finde es auch nicht so schlimm.
Es ist ja ihre Entscheidung,
was die mit der Arbeitszeit machen.
Ich habe auch 50% gemiete.
Wenn nicht sogar mehr manche Wochen.
Wie gesagt, die GoPro habe ich bestellt.
Ist sogar schon da.
Ging hyper schnell.
In welcher Branche ist dein Versicherungsverfahren?
Eine Versicherung in Frankfurt.
Davor war ich bei einer Bank in Frankfurt.
Am Main.
Die GoPro war gestern sogar schon da.
Kann auch sein.
Ich bin ja nicht umsonst
Senior bis Sec-Win-DevOps-Engineer.
Ein Valomat machen wir nicht jetzt.
So soll er nicht gebildet werden.
Aber ich werde tatsächlich
ein paar Runden aufnehmen,
dass ich was für Hintergrund habe.
Das ist echt eine gute Idee.
Ab und zu mal so ein bisschen.
Ich fahre durchs Feld bei Sonnenschein.
Das ist, glaube ich, ganz nice.
Yep, Glock, Leute.
11 Uhr, äh, nicht 11 Uhr.
21 oder 20.
Ich gehe jetzt mal ein bisschen stream gucken
oder irgendwas und dann gehe ich pennen,
da ich morgen früh 7 Uhr aufstehen kann.
Morgen früh dann wieder
die Pisser von der Bahn flamen.
Kann ich wieder ausrasten.
Das Windows 11 Release ist raus.
Pog.
Kann ich wieder ausflippen
über die Bahn.
Ich übertreibe es ja schon teilweise ein bisschen,
muss ich mal echt sagen.
Lest euch das mal durch.
Aber ich bin da halt wirklich sauer.
Ich bin da wirklich extremely angepisst,
wenn es bei der Bahn nicht läuft.
Ich meine, ich übertreibe es da schon ein bisschen,
aber es ist so im Affekt immer.
Was passiert denn da?
Ah, ich bin übrigens immer noch von MSI geblockt auf Twitter.
Ich weiß immer noch nicht, warum.
Äh, Twitter, Twitter-Reader,
der nicht so nervig ist wie Twitter.
Ich weiß wirklich nicht, warum.
Ich habe mal einen Witz gemacht über ein RGB-Mainboard.
Das ist Jahre her.
Vielleicht haben sie mich deswegen geflamen,
sonst hatte ich mit MSI nie was zu tun.
Weiß nicht.
Okay, Leute, ihr hört uns.
Macht es gut, bis dann.